ALL RIGHT. THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY HAS BEGUN. WE
ARE MEETING TODAY IN ROOM 2200
OF THE Ó STREET BUILDING. WE
HAVE 26 BILLS ON THE CALENDAR. I
DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT WE
HAVE AB 1990 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WENDY CARRILLO, WHICH HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA. TEN
BILLS ARE ON CONSENT AB 1863 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. AB 2695
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. AB
2040 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON.
AB 2521 BY ASSEMBLY. WALDRON. AB
2740 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WALDRON
AB 2475 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY. AB 2818 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS. AB 2907 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURR. AB 2984 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON. AB 2032
35 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN. IN
THIS COMMITTEE, THE AUTHOR WILL
PRESENT THEIR BILL FROM THE
PODIUM HERE. WITNESSES WILL
TESTIFY FROM THE MICROPHONE
OUTSIDE THE WELL OVER THERE,
EACH BILL CAN HAVE TWO MAIN
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
MAIN WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
EACH OF THOSE WITNESSES GET TWO
MINUTES EACH, AND WE WILL TIME
THEM AFTER THE MAIN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TESTIFY. WE WILL TAKE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
ME TOOS. STATE YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE TO KEEP OUR
BUSY HEARING GOING. IF YOU ARE
ME TO PLEASE BE LINED UP AND
READY TO GO, WE DO TAKE AUTHORS
AS THEY ARRIVE. IN ORDER TO BE
AS EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE, WE
NEED TO BREAK A LITTLE BIT
BEFORE NOON, AS WE HAVE CAUCUS,
AND WE WOULD PREFER TO GET THIS
DONE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. SO
WITH THAT, I'LL ASK FOR ROLL TO
BE CALLED TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
WAHAB HERE. WAHAB HERE. SATO.
SATO. HERE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
HERE SKINNER. WIENER. THANK YOU.
A QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED.
I'D LIKE A MOTION FOR CONSENT.
MOVE TO CONSENT. SENATOR SATO
MOVES THE CONSENT ITEMS. CAN WE
GET A ROLL CALL? WAHAB AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. SATO. SATO. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. SKINNER
WIENER. ALL RIGHT. THAT WILL
CONSENT WILL BE ON CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR
FIRST PRESENTER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO PRESENTING AB 1856.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF ON THEIR WORK ON THE
ANALYSIS AS WELL AS WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE. I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT AB 1856 WOULD MAKE A
MISDEMEANOR FOR A PERSON WHO
KNOWINGLY CREATED AND
DISTRIBUTED ARTIFICIALLY
GENERATED SEXUAL IMAGES AND
VIDEO WITHOUT THE DEPICTED
INDIVIDUAL CONSENT. ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE CAN ALSO BE USED TO
CREATE DEEPFAKE, COMPUTER
GENERATED IMAGES AND VIDEO OF
PEOPLE THAT APPEAR GENUINE.
DEEPFAKE TECHNOLOGY HAS BECOME
MORE WIDELY ACCESSIBLE IN RECENT
YEARS. IT CAN BE USED TO QUICKLY
CREATE FAKE DIGITAL CONTENT THAT
IS SO REALISTIC THAT IT IS
DIFFICULT TO TELL WHETHER IT IS
ACCURATE. OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL WILL STATE THAT IT MAY BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, BUT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF AI GENERATED
CONTENT OF SOMEONE WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT CAN CONSTITUTE
DEFAMATION OR PORTRAYING SOMEONE
IS A FALSE LIGHT, BOTH OF WHICH
ARE NOT PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS TO FILE CIVIL
LAWSUITS. HOWEVER, THAT ACTION
IS NOT ACCESSIBLE TO MOST
PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME,
WHO DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
FILE A CIVIL SUIT. AS MANY NEW
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY,
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE, CAN
IMPROVE PEOPLE'S LIVES. HOWEVER,
THEY MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO
FABRICATE DIGITAL MEDIA WITHOUT
CONSENT. THEY POSE A SEVERE
THREAT TO THE HEALTH,
REPUTATION, AND FINANCIAL AND
MENTAL STABILITY OF TARGETED
INDIVIDUALS. I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MARK BRICKMAN WITH THE
ORGANIZATION FOR SOCIAL MEDIA
SAFETY, AND GARRETT HAMILTON
WITH CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. AND I RESPECT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IVO.
THANK YOU. YOU'LL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR, VICE CHAIR AND ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION OF
AB 1856. MY NAME IS MARK
BERKMAN. I'M THE CEO OF THE
ORGANIZATION FOR SOCIAL MEDIA
SAFETY, THE LEADING CONSUMER
PROTECTION ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
EXCLUSIVELY ON SOCIAL MEDIA. WE
ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR AB 1856,
WHICH RESPONDS TO THE NEW AND
FRIGHTENING DANGER CREATED BY
DEEPFAKE TECHNOLOGY,
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS CASE,
MALICIOUS DEEPFAKES. AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD DISCUSSED, DEEPFAKES
ARE FORGED VIDEOS CREATED VIA
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE, WHERE A
PERSON'S LIKENESS, INCLUDING
THEIR FACE AND VOICE, IS
REALISTICALLY SWAPPED WITH
SOMEONE ELSE'S. TO BE CLEAR,
DEEPFAKES LOOK REAL. THIS IS NOT
AN ABILITY WE HAVE SEEN BEFORE.
OUTSIDE OF HOLLYWOOD, AND
BECAUSE OF THIS HYPER REALISM OF
DEEPFAKE TECHNOLOGY, WE HAVE
BEEN DEEPLY CONCERNED BY ITS
POTENTIAL FOR CYBERBULLYING,
HARASSMENT AND EXPLOITATION. AND
THERE IS EVIDENCE FOR THIS
CONCERN. SINCE THE INTRODUCTION
OF DEEPFAKES IN LATE 2016, THEY
HAVE ALREADY BEEN USED
EXTENSIVELY TO INSERT WOMEN'S
LIKENESSES INTO FILMS WITHOUT
CONSENT. I SPOKE IN FRONT OF THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
BACK IN 2019, SPONSORING SIMILAR
LEGISLATION WARNING ABOUT THE
FUTURE HARM THIS TECHNOLOGY
WOULD CAUSE. WELL, TRAGICALLY,
THAT HARM HAS NOW BEEN INFLICTED
ON HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS,
INCLUDING ON CALIFORNIANS, AND
THE HARM IS GROWING. IN 2016,
RESEARCHERS IDENTIFIED ONE
DEEPFAKE VIDEO ONLINE. IN THE
FIRST THREE QUARTERS OF 2023,
OVER 143,000 NEW DEEPFAKE VIDEOS
WERE UPLOADED TO THE 40 MOST
USED DEEPFAKE SITES. THANK YOU.
THAT'S TWO MINUTES. WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT SPEAKER. GOOD
MORNING, GARRET HAMILTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 15, 1856. THERE
NEEDS TO BE CRIMINAL
CONSEQUENCES FOR THIS ABHORRENT
BEHAVIOR. THIS IS A REALLY GOOD
START. CREATING AS WELL AS
DISTRIBUTING THESE DEEPFAKES
WILL BE ILLEGAL IF THIS BILL
BECOMES LAW IN COURT. THESE
CASES SHOULD BE RELATIVELY EASY
TO PROVE AS THE EVIDENCE WILL BE
DIGITAL. AND PROVING THAT IT WAS
DISTRIBUTED WILL HAVE A DIGITAL
TRAIL THAT WE BELIEVE IS AN
IMPORTANT AND THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
TO DETER THIS CONDUCT. CD-R IS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CAN WE
HAVE LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS Dð COONEY WITH ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE POTENTIAL HARMS
CAUSED BY DEEPFAKE TECHNOLOGY,
WE FEAR THAT AB 1856 IMPROPERLY
RESTRICTS LAWFUL SPEECH AND RUNS
AFOUL OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
ADDITIONALLY WE OPPOSE 1856
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IT WILL HAVE
A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
YOUNG PEOPLE. WE FEAR THAT AB
1856 WILL RESULT IN FURTHER
CRIMINALIZATION OF YOUTH,
PARTICULARLY YOUTH OF COLOR, WHO
ENGAGE IN THE PRESCRIBED
BEHAVIOR. A RECENT STUDY FOUND
THAT 73% OF TEENAGERS 17 OR
OLDER HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO
ONLINE. YOUNG PEOPLE ACCESS
THESE MATERIALS IN A VARIETY OF
WAYS, INCLUDING SHARING WITH ONE
ANOTHER THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA.
UNDER 1856, A YOUNG PERSON COULD
BE CONVICTED OF A CRIME AND
SENTENCED TO JAIL IF THEY SHARE
DEEPFAKE WITH A PEER UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES, THE BILL
OUTLINES. WHILE THIS CONDUCT MAY
BE INAPPROPRIATE AND SOMETIMES
HARMFUL, SENDING YOUNG PEOPLE TO
JAIL SEEMS OVERLY PUNITIVE AND
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE URGE A NO A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER LEAD OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ME TO AGAIN STATE YOUR
NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION, WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS, CORY SALZILLO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIRMAN, ASSEMBLY SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN OPPOSITION, THANK YOU.
SEEING NOBODY ELSE, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
SENATOR SALADO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD, I DISAGREE WITH
THE OPPONENTS OF THIS AS FAR AS
WHOSE RIGHTS ARE BEING VIOLATED,
THE PRETENSE ARE THE SUPPOSITION
THAT SOMEHOW THIS IS A GOING TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT. I'VE
HEARD THAT ARGUMENT SO MANY
TIMES. AND THIS PARTICULAR ONE,
IT STRIKES ME AS ODD, THE
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY ENGAGE AND
DO THESE, YOU KNOW, THERE'S A
LOT OF TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGICALLY ADVANCED, MINORS
OUT THERE. ALL OF THEM HAVE THAT
CAPABILITY, THIS PERMEATES
DISTRICTS ALL OVER THE
SOUTHLAND, IN OUR SCHOOLS, THE
SCHOOLS OUT IN MY DISTRICT,
THESE ARE THE THINGS WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT YOUTH SUICIDE, WHEN
THEY GET SUBJECTED TO THIS
HAPPENING TO THEM. THESE ARE
THOSE SPONTANEOUS. WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED. MOMENTS
FOR PARENTS AND FOR US TO BE
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT PROTECTING
THE RIGHTS OF SOMEBODY WHO GOES
THROUGH A PROCESS. THIS ISN'T
EASY TO DO. IF YOU ASK ME TO DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS. ONLY NOT
EVEN I COULDN'T DO IT. I DON'T
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGICAL SKILLS TO
DO THAT, NOR DO I HAVE THE TIME
TO DO IT. SOMEBODY HAS TO
PURPOSELY DO THIS AND GO AFTER
AND VIOLATE, THE GOODS, YOU
KNOW, THE, THE NAME OF AND IMAGE
OF SOMEBODY, FOR THIS TO, TO
OCCUR. SO YOU KNOW, I WILL BE
SUPPORTING A BILL, I WILL MAKE A
MOTION SINCE SINCE, IT IS
CORRECT, BUT I APPRECIATE US
ACTUALLY TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS, BECAUSE IT IS A
SCOURGE AND THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ENGAGING IT NEED TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT A SCOURGE IT IS AND NOT BE
DEFENDED OR MADE EXCUSES FOR
WHEN THEY DO THIS STUFF. ONCE,
ONCE PEOPLE KNOW IT'S ILLEGAL,
THEY BETTER STOP. SO, YOU KNOW,
AGAIN, I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
BRINGING THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU, SENATOR, SINCE
WE HAVE A MOTION,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES. I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT. AND I
WANT TO THANK, THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IVO. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SERRANO. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL,
PLEASE? ITEM FOUR AB 1856. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB, I HOPE
I SATO. SATO. I BRADFORD.
SKINNER. WIENER ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL IS ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, WE'RE NEXT GOING TO HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN,
PRESENT, AND I WILL BE HANDING
IT OVER TO SENATOR SATO FOR A
LITTLE BIT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. AB 364
WOULD REQUIRE MANUFACTURERS OF
FIREARM SAFETY DEVICES TO MARK
THEIR PRODUCTS WITH MAKE AND
MODEL INFORMATION FOR FIREARM
SAFETY DEVICES. LAW CAN PREVENT
UNAUTHORIZED USERS FROM
DISCHARGING A FIREARM, AND MUST
BE USED WHEN A FIREARM IS
TRANSFERRED THROUGH A DEALER OR
WHEN TRANSPORTED IN SENSITIVE
PLACES, SIMILAR TO THE HANDGUN
ROSTER. THE DOJ MAINTAINS A
ROSTER OF LABORATORY TESTED,
APPROVED FIREARM SAFETY DEVICES
LISTED BY MANUFACTURER, MODEL
NAME, AND MODEL NUMBER. HOWEVER
MANUFACTURERS ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO PLACE THIS SAME INFORMATION
ON THE ACTUAL DEVICES, MAKING IT
NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CONSUMERS TO
TELL ONE FROM ANOTHER, MUCH LESS
AN APPROVED DEVICE, VERSUS AN
INEFFECTIVE LOOK ALIKE. MORE
IMPORTANTLY, IF A CONSUMER OWNS
A SAFETY DEVICE THAT HAS BEEN
RECALLED IS DEFECTIVE, OR HAS A
WARRANTY ISSUE, THEY ARE UNABLE
TO IDENTIFY IF THEIR DEVICE IS
AFFECTED. THIS MAY RESULT IN THE
CONTINUED USE OF AN UNSAFE OR
INEFFECTIVE DEVICE. AB 3064 WILL
REQUIRE FIREARM SAFETY DEVICE
MANUFACTURERS TO PLACE, MAKE,
AND MODEL INFORMATION IN A
VISIBLE LOCATION ON THE PRODUCT.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
MANUFACTURERS TO NOTIFY THE DOJ
IN THE EVENT OF A RECALL, AND IT
AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT TO
CHARGE A FEE ON MANUFACTURERS TO
HAVE THEIR DEVICE LISTED ON THE
ROSTER. THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
BILL TO ASSIST BOTH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CONSUMERS. Ã
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL, CANDICE CHUNG, AND
PETER WALD, ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
OF THE BUREAU OF FIREARMS. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, THANK YOU FOR
TESTIFYING THIS MORNING.
REMEMBER, YOU DO HAVE TWO
MINUTES. OKAY. AND I WILL ADHERE
TO THE CHAIR'S RULES. OKAY? I DO
NOT GET IN TROUBLE. AND SUFFER.
I WILL MAKE SURE YOU DON'T GET
IN TROUBLE. GOOD MORNING.
SENATORS. MY NAME IS CANDICE
CHUNG. I'M A DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. AND ON
BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB
BONTA, WHO IS THE PROUD SPONSOR
OF AB 3064, WE'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS VERY
THOROUGH AND DETAILED ANALYSIS,
AS WELL AS TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN FOR AUTHORING
THIS BILL TO PROMOTE THE SAFE,
EFFECTIVE, SAFE STORAGE OF
FIREARMS AND TO MODERNIZE THE
REPORTING PROCESS. AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED,
CURRENT LAW ALREADY REQUIRES THE
USE OF AN APPROVED FIREARM
SAFETY DEVICE IN CERTAIN
SITUATIONS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
EXPAND OR ALTER WHEN AND HOW
THESE DEVICES ARE TO BE USED. IT
SIMPLY REQUIRES MANUFACTURERS TO
PLACE, MAKE, AND MODEL
INFORMATION ON THEIR PRODUCTS.
JUST LIKE PRETTY MUCH EVERY
OTHER CONSUMER SAFETY PRODUCT ON
THE MARKET TODAY, THERE ARE OVER
2300 DIFFERENT MODELS ON THE
DOJ'S ROSTER OF LAB TESTED,
APPROVED STATE FIREARM SAFETY
DEVICES AND OF THOSE,
APPROXIMATELY 75% CONTAIN NO
HAVE NO IDENTIFYING MARKINGS ON
THE OUTSIDE OF THE ACTUAL
DEVICE, SIMPLY BECAUSE
MANUFACTURERS ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO DO SO. AND SO MANY OF THESE
DEVICES LOOK EXACTLY ALIKE. I
MEAN, THEY'RE JUST A LOT OF
TIMES THEY'RE LIKE PLAIN METAL,
BLACK METAL BOXES OR PADLOCK AND
CABLE COMBINATIONS WITHOUT
MARKINGS. IT'S PRETTY MUCH
IMPOSSIBLE TO DISCERN JUST BY
LOOKING AT IT. THE MAKE AND
MODEL. SO THIS IS REALLY YOU
KNOW, THIS IS ALSO A BIG
CONSUMER SAFETY ISSUE, LIKE IT
WAS MENTIONED, CONSUMERS CAN'T
TELL IF THEY'RE IF A MODEL IS
RECALLED AND THAT HAPPENS. THERE
WERE SEVEN MODELS RECALLED IN
OCTOBER. ANOTHER THREE IN
FEBRUARY, YOU CAN'T TELL LIKE
WHETHER OR NOT YOUR DEVICE IS
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE AFFECTED
ONES, SO YOU KNOW, AND THE GOAL
OF THIS BILL IS REALLY TO HELP
PEOPLE KNOW THAT THE DEVICE THAT
THEY'RE USING IS SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE. WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
INCREASE CRIMINAL PENALTIES OR
MAKE IT HARDER FOR MANUFACTURERS
TO DO BUSINESS. BUT THESE
DEVICES ARE DESIGNED TO PREVENT
UNAUTHORIZED PERSONS, LIKE KIDS
FROM ACCESSING GUNS. SO THE
CONSEQUENCES OF UNKNOWINGLY
USING A FAULTY DEVICE ARE HIGH,
ADDITIONALLY, THIS BILL WILL
MODERNIZE THE EXISTING PROCESSES
WITHIN THE BUREAU OF FIREARMS TO
REPORT, CERTAIN SELF-REPORTED
FIREARMS TRANSACTIONS, SUCH AS
THE PURCHASE OF ANTIQUES, OR
WHEN A NEW RESIDENT MOVES INTO
THE STATE WITH THEIR GUNS,
CURRENTLY, ALTHOUGH THE DOJ'S
SYSTEMS CAN ALREADY ACCEPT THESE
REPORTS FOR ELECTRONICALLY, THE
STATUTE STATES THAT THEY MUST BE
SUBMITTED BY MAIL OR. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THAT'S HOW SHE DOES
IT. SO SORRY. AGAIN. WE JUST WE
HAVE ANOTHER, WE I HAVE, THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF THE BUREAU
OF FIREARMS, PETER WOLD, HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. AT THIS TIME, WE'LL TAKE,
OPPOSITION, LEAD WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, SIR.
COMING UP, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
I KNOW. OKAY, MR. MR. CHAIRMAN,
MEMBERS, AB 3064 ANNUAL FEE ON
MANUFACTURERS OR IMPORTERS WHO
SELL ANY FIREARM DEVICE LISTED
ON THE DEPARTMENT'S SAFETY
ROSTER WILL DO ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING FOR SAFETY. AS A MATTER
OF FACT, WE HAVE MILLIONS OF
SAFETY DEVICES THAT ARE
PRESENTLY USED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND THEY
ARE DOING JUST THAT. BUT HERE,
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
GOING TO SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT? ALL
OF THOSE SUCCESSFUL SAFETY
DEVICES ARE NOW INVALID BECAUSE
THEY HAVEN'T PAID THEIR FEE AND
BEEN APPROVED BY US. AND IF
SOMEBODY GETS LISTED ON THE ON
THE ROSTER AND FOR SOME REASON,
THEY STOP MANUFACTURING THAT
SAFE, THAT DEVICE AND THEY DROP
OFF THE ROSTER, EVERYBODY WHO
HAS THAT DEVICE IN PRIVATE USE
IS NOW UP IN POSSESSION OF A ONE
THAT IS NOT DECLARED SAFE BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, THIS IS
GOING TO PUT MANY LAW ABIDING
GUN OWNERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA INTO A VERY
PRECARIOUS DECISION. YOU KNOW,
THE, THE, THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
REGARDING VOLUNTARY REPORTING,
EXEMPTED TRANSACTIONS ARE
COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY. AND THIS
SERVES NO CRIME-FIGHTING PURPOSE
AT ALL. FINALLY, I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT, THE SUPREME
COURT AFFIRMED THAT THE NEED FOR
DEFENSE OF SELF, FAMILY AND
PROPERTY IS MOST ACUTE IN THE
HOME AND THE SECOND AMENDMENT
ELEVATES ABOVE ALL OTHER
INTERESTS THE RIGHT TO USE ARMS
IN DEFENSE OF HEARTH AND HOME.
THE HELLER DECISION WAS ROOTED
ON THE FACT THAT IT IS NOT
ALLOWED FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REQUIRE PEOPLE TO
KEEP THEIR GUNS LOCKED UP OR
DISASSEMBLED IN SOME MANNER
WHERE THEY ARE NOT IMMEDIATELY
AVAILABLE TO THEM FOR, DEFENSE
IN THE HOME. THAT'S WHAT THE
RULING SAID. THIS BILL GOES
COMPLETELY CONTRARY TO THAT. AND
THAT'S WHY, GUN OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA, THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION, THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
AT THIS TIME, WE'LL TAKE THE
METOOS. ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION OR
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL CAN COME UP
STATE YOUR NAME, THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT, AND
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL, SIMPLY GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH ROSEMAY,
AND, I'M A CONCERNED CITIZEN. I
DON'T THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
COSMIC CHARGE MANUFACTURERS A
FEE TO SELL THEIR PRODUCT HERE.
OKAY. MA'AM, ARE YOU SPEAKING AS
A PRIMARY WITNESS? I'M SORRY.
THEN I MAY HAVE JUMPED THE GUN
BECAUSE WE ARE ALLOWING TWO AND
YOU CAN SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU, ANYWAY, I
DON'T THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
CHARGE MANUFACTURERS OF A
PRODUCT TO SELL THEIR ITEMS
HERE. I ALSO, I'M A TWO TIME
VIOLENT CRIME SURVIVOR, AND I
LIVE ALONE WITH ALEXIS. AND I
WANT TO HAVE A GUN THAT'S READY
TO GO IF MY HOUSE OR ME ARE
ASSAULTED. I HAVE A CCW AND
THAT'S PART OF HOW I GET ALONG
IN THE WORLD AS FAR AS THE
ACTUAL ROSTER OF GUN SAFES ARE
GOING TO PLACE AN UNNECESSARY
BURDEN ON LAWFUL, RESPONSIBLE
PEOPLE WHO ALREADY HAVE SAFES
THAT ARE WORKING FINE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION. I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MA'AM, AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
SKIPPING OVER YOU THE FIRST
TIME. NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE
METOOS. THIS IS WHEN PEOPLE CAN
COME UP. LET ME KNOW YOUR NAME.
THE ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT,
AND ALSO WHETHER YOU SIMPLY
WHETHER YOU OPPOSE OR SUPPORT
THE BILL. IF THERE ARE NO
METOOS, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DÍAS FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR
QUESTIONS. WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL BY BRADFORD. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ITEM NUMBER 24 AB 3064. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WAHAB. CIERTO CIERTO NÓ
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I SKINNER.
WIENER THANK YOU. OKAY. THAT
BRINGS US UP TO. I HAVE TO GO
SEARCH FOR THE FILE FOR THE NEXT
PERSON. SINCE WE'RE OUT OF
ORDER. ZEBRA ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ZEBRA. IT LOOKS LIKE AB 2917.
FOR AGENDA TWO. YEAH. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS, I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 2917, WHICH IS
SPONSORED BY EVERYTOWN FOR GUN
SAFETY AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. THIS
BILL UPDATES AND REFINES THE
CALIFORNIA'S NATION LEADING GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER,
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS GROW LAW, TO
DRAW THE CIVIL COURT'S ATTENTION
TO A BROADER SET OF FACTORS IN A
COURT'S ANALYSIS OF WHETHER
TEMPORARY ACCESS TO FIREARMS
SHOULD BE RESTRICTED ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S MOST RECENT REPORT ON
HATE CRIMES IN CALIFORNIA, HATE
CRIME EVENTS INVOLVING RACIAL
BIAS, RELIGIOUS BIAS, SEXUAL
ORIENTATION BIAS, AND GENDER
BIAS ALL INCREASED BETWEEN 2021
AND 2022. WE HAVE TO STRENGTHEN
OUR TOOLS TO PREVENT HATE BASED
VIOLENCE, ESPECIALLY THE
ALARMING RATES OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITIES,
ESPECIALLY TRANS WOMEN.
RELIGIOUS MINORITIES, INCLUDING
PEOPLE OF JEWISH AND ISLAMIC
FAITH, AND MINORITY RACIAL AND
ETHNIC COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL
GUIDES THE COURT TO CONSIDER
THREATS OF VIOLENCE MADE AGAINST
GROUPS PROTECTED BY HATE CRIMES,
LAWS AND THREATS OF VIOLENCE TO
ADVANCE POLITICAL OBJECTIVES. IT
ALSO UPDATES VARIOUS STATUTES TO
CODIFY THE ABILITY OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY ATTORNEYS PURSUING
GROWS TO ACCESS CRIMINAL HISTORY
INFORMATION. CALIFORNIA'S GVR
LAW CREATED A CIVIL LEGAL
PROCESS THROUGH WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT CONCERNED FAMILY
MEMBERS AND OTHER DESIGNATED
INDIVIDUALS MAY REQUEST A COURT
ORDER. A REQUEST THAT A COURT
GRANTED ORDER TEMPORARILY
RESTRICTING A PERSON'S ACCESS TO
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION. WHEN
THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT THE PERSON
POSES A SIGNIFICANT RISK OF HARM
TO THEMSELVES OR TO OTHERS. IN
THE DECADES SINCE THE LAW WAS
PASSED, SROS HAVE BECOME ONE OF
THE MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS
AVAILABLE FOR PREVENTING CERTAIN
TYPES OF GUN VIOLENCE. BEFORE IT
OCCURS BY PROMPTLY AND
TEMPORARILY REMOVING FIREARMS
FROM A PERSON AT RISK OF HARMING
OTHERS OR THEMSELVES. GROWS CAN
BE PARTICULARLY USEFUL FOR
PREVENTING MASS SHOOTINGS AND
SUICIDE. OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES DESERVE PROTECTION,
INCLUDING PROTECTION FROM GUN
VIOLENCE. CALIFORNIA COURTS MUST
STAY ALERT TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
CONSIDERING THREATS OF HATE
BASED VIOLENCE AND THREATS OF
POLITICAL VIOLENCE. WHEN
TEMPORARILY RESTRICTING ACCESS
TO GUNS, THEREBY PREVENTING
NEEDLESS DEATHS AND POTENTIALLY
SAVING INNOCENT LIVES. WHEN THE
WARNING SIGNS ARE THERE AND WE
SEE SOMEONE THREATEN VIOLENCE
BECAUSE OF HATE OR EXTREMIST
IDEOLOGY, WE MUST USE THE TOOLS
NECESSARY TO PREVENT TRAGEDY. I
ASK YOUR VOTE, YOUR AYE VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. AND WITH
ME TODAY IS REBECCA KRELL,
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING TODAY. AND
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. GREAT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. I'M REBECCA KROLL
HERE REPRESENTING SAN FRANCISCO
CITY ATTORNEY DAVID CHIU. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON AB 2917 TODAY, THE
SAN FRANCISCO CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE APPRECIATES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ZIBA'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND IS GRATEFUL
TO PARTNER WITH EVERYTOWN FOR
GUN SAFETY ON THIS LEGISLATION.
AS YOU ALL KNOW, IMPACTFUL LAWS
REQUIRE EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION
AND ENFORCEMENT AS LEGAL COUNSEL
TO THEIR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES, CALIFORNIA CITY
ATTORNEYS, AND COUNTY COUNSEL
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF
IMPLEMENTING GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS, WHICH ARE
CIVIL ORDERS WITHIN THE
AUTHORITY OF OUR OFFICES.
SECTIONS ONE THROUGH THREE OF AB
2917 ARE A NARROWLY SCOPED
UPDATE TO THE LAW TO FACILITATE
IMPLEMENTATION BY STREAMLINING
THE ABILITY OF CITY ATTORNEYS
AND COUNTY COUNCILS TO ACCESS
CRIMINAL HISTORY INFORMATION AS
PART OF THEIR WORK. PARTNERING
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
FILE AND PROCESS PETITIONS,
INCLUDING CRIMINAL HISTORY
INFORMATION IS CRITICAL TO A
SUCCESSFUL GCVO PETITION. THE
SAN FRANCISCO CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE FIRST BEGAN SEEKING GROWS
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE DEPARTMENT IN 2019
THROUGH OUR OFFICE'S OUTREACH
WITH GUN SAFETY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT, THE NUMBER OF GROWS
SOUGHT BY OUR OFFICE AND THE
NUMBER OF FIREARMS SEIZED
PURSUANT TO GV. SROS HAVE
INCREASED STEADILY IN SAN
FRANCISCO. THE CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IS INVOLVED IN EVERY
SINGLE GROW SOUGHT BY THE SFPD,
AND COORDINATED PARTNERSHIP IS
CRITICAL TO OUR SUCCESS. AB 2917
ALSO HAS THE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL
PROSECUTORS COALITION. THE
COALITION SERVES MANY OF THE
LARGEST CITY ATTORNEY AND COUNTY
COUNSEL'S OFFICES IN CALIFORNIA,
REPRESENTING MILLIONS OF
RESIDENTS IN OUR JURISDICTIONS.
IMPROVING PUBLIC SAFETY LAWS
GEARED TOWARDS PREVENTING GUN
VIOLENCE GROWS IS A TOP
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY FOR US THIS
YEAR. THE COALITION IS CHAIRED
BY SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY MARA
ELLIOTT, WHO HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED
AS A NATIONAL LEADER IN GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? IF THERE
ARE NO THERE ARE NO OTHERS, THEN
WE WILL TAKE LEAD WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION. ANY LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. WELCOME. YOU KNOW
THE DRILL. WE GOT TWO MINUTES,
MR. CHAIRMAN. THIS LEGISLATION
IS VERY PROBLEMATIC GIVEN THAT
VIOLENT SPEECH, ALTHOUGH VERY
DETESTABLE, IS NOT BY ANY MEANS
CONSIDERED OBJECTIVE. IT DEPENDS
ON WHO'S DOING THE DECIDING AS
TO WHAT CONSTITUTES VIOLENT
SPEECH. LIKE IT OR NOT, THE
FIRST AMENDMENT PROTECTS FREEDOM
OF SPEECH, EVEN IF IT'S UGLY.
WITHOUT QUESTION, THE DEFINITION
OF VERBAL OR WRITTEN THREATS
AGAINST VIOLENCE IS EXTREMELY
SUBJECTIVE. REGARDING THE
ADVANCEMENT OF A POLITICAL
AGENDA, I MEAN BY A LOT OF
STANDARDS, DISPLAYING THE
AMERICAN FLAG IS CONSIDERED
VIOLENT. THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT
IS A PROBLEM. YOU KNOW, THE MERE
FACT THAT GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS HAVE BEEN
ISSUED. THERE IS NO SCIENTIFIC
METHODOLOGY TO PROVE THAT THEY
ARE EFFECTIVE IN PREVENTING ANY
SORT OF A VIOLENT CRIME. IT'S
NOT POSSIBLE. IT'S LIKE SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO END CAR ACCIDENTS
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET
ANYBODY DRIVE. IT JUST DOESN'T,
MAKE ANY SENSE. ALSO, THE, GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS WERE
RECENTLY, THE TOPIC OF A UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT CASE IN
RAHIMI VERSUS THE UNITED STATES.
IN THIS CASE, THE COURT SAID
THAT THERE HAS TO BE A LEGAL
FINDING IN ORDER TO JUSTIFY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS. WHAT IS A LEGAL FINDING?
THAT MEANS THAT BOTH SIDES OF
THE OF THE CASE ARE LISTENED TO
BEFORE THEY CAN DO A RESTRAINING
ORDER, AND IT IS TEMPORARY. THEY
ALSO DISCUSSED THAT RED FLAG
LAWS OR GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS WILL BE DEALT WITH IN
FUTURE CASES. FOR THOSE REASONS,
GUN OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA, THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION, AND THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION ARE STRONGLY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THIS MORNING. IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE AS A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS? YOUR LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS? YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING. I'M
ELIZABETH ROSE MAY. I'M A
CONCERNED CITIZEN. I KNOW WHO
YOU ARE, BUT PARDON ME. ONE OF
THE DIFFICULTIES WITH GROWS IS
THAT, THEY CAN BE MOTIVATED AND
PURSUED SIMPLY ON THE BASIS OF
GOSSIP. NOT NECESSARILY ANY HARD
FACTS. AND IT IS PROBLEMATIC. SO
THANK YOU. AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. MR. CHAIRMAN. SAM
PAREDES, FOR THE RECORD, I'M THE
ONE WHO'S DOING THE TESTIMONY. I
NEGLECTED TO MENTION MY NAME IN
BOTH, BOTH BILLS THAT I'VE
TESTIFIED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR CLARIFYING, SAM. APPRECIATE
IT. OKAY. AT THIS POINT, WE WILL
TAKE THE ME TO ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION OR IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL CAN COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE, STATE YOUR NAME, THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT, AND
WHETHER YOU OPPOSE OR SUPPORT
THE BILL. MR. CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS,
DAN FALLACARO, ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GARRETT HAMILTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. ANA ARCHIMEDES WITH LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. Dð COONEY ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION. WE
HAVE NO POSITION, BUT WE'VE
CONVEYED OUR CONCERNS AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING RESPONSIVE TO US.
THANK YOU. DIANA HOENIG,
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BRIDGET JACOBOWITZ, VOLUNTEER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER AND STRONG
SUPPORT. SUSAN BURNS, VOLUNTEER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. YARA JHADOL
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AND STRONG SUPPORT AMY
SERAPION, VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, LAURA LANE WITH
EVERYTOWN FOR GUN SAFETY IN
SUPPORT. THANKS. THAT WAS ME TO
SEEING NO OTHER SPEAKERS. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR SKINNER,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL, I WILL MOVE
IT. I APPRECIATE YOUR THE BILL
THAT WAS ON CONSENT, AND THIS
ONE GROWS. I AM THE AUTHOR OF
THE ORIGINAL LAW. ARE CAN BE A
VERY EFFECTIVE TOOL. HOWEVER
THEY HAVE BEEN USED LESS THAN WE
WOULD HOPE. AND THERE, VARIETY
OF REASONS FOR THAT, LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE SOME OF IT IS
ONE OF THE EASIER WAYS TO THAT.
IF YOU ARE AWARE OF SOMEONE WHO
IS, YOU HAVE CREDIBLE EVIDENCE
OF A PERSON WHO IS MAKING
THREATS OF VIOLENCE TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS. THEN ONE
OF THE MOST, AVAILABLE WAYS IS
TO GO TO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BUT OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
NOT ALWAYS AWARE OR FULLY
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO ISSUE THEM
AND SUCH, OR WHAT IS NEEDED. AND
SO I THINK YOUR EXPANSION OF
ENABLING, GIVING ADDITIONAL
REASONS FOR THE ISSUING OF A
GROW AND THE EXPANSION OF
ALLOWING CITY ATTORNEYS OR
COUNTY COUNSEL TO HELP, I THINK
THE MORE THE MORE PEOPLE IN
ROLES LIKE THAT, THAT UNDERSTAND
THIS TOOL AND CAN ASSIST SOMEONE
IN, IN OBTAINING IT WOULD HELP
MAKE IT REALLY EFFECTIVE. SO I
APPRECIATE THE BILL. AND LIKE I
SAID, I MOVE IT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, DID YOU MAKE A MOTION
TO MOVE? OKAY. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES. OH, SORRY.
SENATOR SERATO. SORRY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO WHILE I AM DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
SHOULDN'T BE CARRYING FIREARMS,
BEING ABLE TO CARRY THEM IN
READING, THIS BILL, THERE IS A
LOT OF BROAD CATEGORIES. AND I'M
KIND OF CURIOUS IN OUR EFFORTS
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS TO KEEP
PEOPLE OUT OF PRISON AS WE
BROADEN THESE CATEGORIES, AND
SOME OF THEM CAN BE VERY, VERY
OBJECTIVE, LIKE ONE OF THE, THE
WITNESSES STATED HERE. AND AS WE
BROADEN THE NET TO CAPTURE
PEOPLE INTO THIS GVR THAT TURNS
THEM INTO A PROHIBITED PERSON,
IF THEY DO HAVE A GUN AND THAT
CAN LEAD TO STATE OR FEDERAL
CRIME CHARGES, CRIMINAL CHARGES,
WHICH PUTS THEM IN JAIL. SO WHAT
HAPPENED TO OUR CONCERN ABOUT
PUTTING PEOPLE IN JAIL FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE LIKE REALLY
DOING CRIMES? NOW WE'RE LOOKING
AT PEOPLE THAT MAY HAVE OR HAVE
BEEN INTERPRETED BY SOMEBODY TO
HAVE THREATENED A, A, AN ACTION
THAT MIGHT NOT EVEN BE A CRIME.
SO WHERE IS THAT LINE? WHERE IS
THAT LINE FOR THIS BILL? SO,
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH, I WAS
ACTUALLY THINKING ABOUT THIS
BILL RELATED TO AN INCIDENT THAT
HAPPENED IN MY DISTRICT JUST
THIS WEEKEND. YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
ABOUT, SOME A, A SO-CALLED
PROTEST OUTSIDE A SYNAGOGUE IN
THE PICO-ROBERTSON DISTRICT OF
MY AREA OF MY DISTRICT. IT WAS
FOLLOWED UP BY ONLINE, THREATS
THAT INCLUDED THREATS OF
VIOLENCE, AND, AND WHEN WE GOT
THAT AND WHEN WE SAW THAT IN OUR
OFFICE, WE ACTUALLY TURNED THAT
WE'RE TURNING THAT OVER TO THE,
TO THE FBI THIS MORNING. WE
FOUND THESE OUT LAST NIGHT, AND
TO THE LA CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
AND TO THE LAPD. NOW FOR
ENFORCEMENT. BUT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
THIS BILL WOULD CLEARLY ALLOW A
STEP THAT IS IN ADDITION TO A
FULL INVESTIGATION TO TAKE PLACE
WHERE THESE FOLKS COULD BE
REMOVED FROM FIREARMS. WHEN WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A VERY CLEAR
THREAT, AND SO, YOU KNOW, IN
RESPONSE TO ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
COMMENTS HERE, THERE NEEDS TO BE
EVIDENCE OF VIOLENCE. AND SO
THERE'S VERY THERE'S A LOT OF
WAYS YOU CAN SHOW THAT. BUT BUT,
YOU KNOW, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
ONLINE THREATS THAT ARE
HAPPENING NOW, IT GIVES LAW
ENFORCEMENT AN INVESTIGATION
TOOL AND AN ABILITY TO REMOVE
THE FIREARMS BEFORE, BEFORE
PEOPLE ARE HARMED. AND IT'S AND
THAT IS A IT IS ANOTHER TOOL,
IT'S A TOOL THAT IS EASIER, THAT
HAS THAT'S A STEP IN BETWEEN
ACTUALLY DOING A FULL
PROSECUTION WHEN SOMEONE HAS
ACTUALLY COMMITTED A CRIME THAT
HAS RESULTED IN VIOLENCE. RIGHT.
WELL, THE CRIMINAL THREAT ITSELF
IS ALREADY A CRIME. SO THEY CAN
BE ARRESTED FOR THAT. BUT ARE WE
PREPARED? BUT IT'S ALSO, YOU
KNOW, CRIMINAL THREAT THAT'S
MORE DIFFUSE WHERE YOU BASICALLY
I MEAN, I HAVE CONSTITUENTS WHO
RAISE THIS WITH ME, WITH MY
OFFICE AND THEY DON'T KNOW WHO
THE SPECIFIC TARGET IS. IT'S THE
KIND OF IT IS A SIGNAL OF
DOMESTIC TERRORISM THAT'S AROUND
THE CORNER. AND THIS WOULD GIVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT A TOOL TO AT
LEAST ACTUALLY SEE IF THEY'VE
ENDED UP, IF THEY'VE GOT
FIREARMS AND REMOVED THEM.
RIGHT. AND THEN WE CAN PUT THEM
IN JAIL. WELL THE, THE NO, YOU
WOULD, YOU WOULD END UP YOU
WOULD HAVE THOSE OTHER TOOLS TO
INVESTIGATE ON THOSE OTHER
PIECES. BUT THIS WOULD ALLOW,
GROWS TO BE ISSUED AS AN, AS AN
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIVE MEASURE.
YEAH. SO AS AN ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIVE MEASURE THOUGH, IF
THERE IF, IF BASICALLY YOU'RE
PUTTING, YOU'RE CASTING THIS NET
AND YOU'RE GOING TO PUT MORE
PEOPLE IN JAIL, WHICH IS
COUNTERINTUITIVE TO THESE
EFFORTS THAT I'VE BEEN LISTENING
TO FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS, TO
PUT LESS PEOPLE IN JAIL. SO I
ACTUALLY DO WANT THE PEOPLE TO
GO TO JAIL THAT VIOLATE, LAWS.
BUT I DON'T WANT PEOPLE CAUGHT
IN AN, IN A SUBJECTIVE, NET, TO
YOU KNOW, TO BE ALSO SWEPT UP
INTO THIS AND CREATE EVEN MORE
OF AN EXCUSE NOT TO HAVE, YOU
KNOW, MORE PEOPLE OUT OF JAIL.
SO, ANYWAY, I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL, I THINK
THAT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS BY NOW, I
THINK IT'S TOO BROAD, AND IT
NEEDS TO BE NARROWED SO THAT WE
KNOW WHO WE'RE ARRESTING AND IT
NEEDS TO HAVE SOME FOLLOW UP. IF
WE ARREST SOMEBODY AND THEY. AND
THEY BREAK THAT LAW, THOSE
PROHIBITED PERSONS, WELL, THEY
NEED TO GO TO JAIL. AND WE'RE
NOT DOING THAT EITHER. SO I'M
NOT QUITE SURE HOW THIS
TRANSLATES INTO SAFER PUBLIC. SO
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MAY I
RESPOND TO THAT? YES YES, THE
WAY IT TRANSLATES INTO SAFER
PUBLIC IS THAT THERE'S IT GIVES
LAW ENFORCEMENT MORE TOOLS TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM ACTUALLY
BEING HURT. AND THAT IS THE THAT
IS THE IMPORTANT THING BEHIND
GROWS. AND, AND IT'S, IT'S ONE
OF THE TOOLS THAT WE DO TO TRY
TO PREVENT ADDITIONAL CRIMES
THAT RESULT IN VIOLENCE AND
HURTING PEOPLE. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE WITH THAT? I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SKINNER. ITEM NUMBER 22,
AB 2917. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB I. WAHAB I
SATO. NO. SATO NO. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I SKINNER. SKINNER I
THAT MOTIONS. I MEAN THAT BILL
IS ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M GOING TO LIFT CONSENT.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0. SKINNER.
SKINNER I WIENER ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S STILL ON CALL. AND THEN
CAN WE ALSO LIFT, FILE NUMBER
24? AB 306 FOR ITEM NUMBER 24,
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
1 TO 1. WAHAB I WAHAB I, SKINNER
WIENER. YES WHICH ITEM NUMBER 24
3064. WE'RE AGAIN MOONSHINE
FIREARMS. YES. SKINNER I ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL IS ON CALL AS
WELL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
PLEASE BEGIN. I THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND SENATORS. TODAY I AM
PRESENTING AB 2138, WHICH WOULD
CREATE A THREE YEAR PILOT
PROJECT WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE GRANTING QUALIFIED
TRIBES PEACE OFFICER STATUS. AND
I ALSO WANT TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. MISSING
AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS PERSONS
IN INDIAN LAND HAS SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN PLAGUING FOR
GENERATIONS OF THOSE THAT GO
MISSING, AND THE LACK OF
INVESTIGATION BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTO THEIR DISAPPEARANCE, THAT
ULTIMATELY ENDS UP MANY TIMES IN
HOMICIDES. HOMICIDES IS STILL
AREN'T BEING INVESTIGATED
PROPERLY. WE'RE CALIFORNIA STILL
SITS AS NUMBER FIVE OF ALL
STATES IN THE NATION OF NOT
INVESTIGATING CRIMES AGAINST
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE ON INDIAN
RESERVATIONS. WE HAVE HAD MANY
ROUNDTABLES ON THIS ISSUE, ONE
WHERE WE HEARD STORIES FROM A
YOUNG YUROK WOMAN WHO TALKED
ABOUT HER PERSONAL ACCOUNTS THAT
TOLD HER PERSONAL STORIES IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
TRULY UNDERSTOOD THE PLIGHT OF
WHAT IS TRULY GOING ON AND
HAPPENING TO CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLED TO RECOUNT
HER OWN FAMILY HISTORY AND THE
TRAUMATIC PAST EXPERIENCE DUE TO
PUBLIC LAW 280, A LAW THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN 1953 THAT
BASICALLY STRIPPED FEDERAL
INDIAN RESERVATIONS OF THE RIGHT
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES. AND THIS
LAW, PUBLIC LAW 280 AND 1953,
WAS NOT CREATED TO PROTECT
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE. IT WAS
CREATED TO PROTECT NON-NATIVES
FROM INDIAN PEOPLE FROM ON THE
RESERVATIONS. THIS PROGRAM TODAY
WILL ADMINISTER UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND RUN
FOR THREE YEARS AS A PILOT
PROGRAM. THIS BILL IS PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE LONG
STANDING EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
PERSON CRISIS HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. TRIBAL POLICING
IN CALIFORNIA CARRIES A DARK
HISTORY, A HISTORY THAT WE MUST
BEGIN TO SHED LIGHT ON AND BRING
FORWARD THAT TRAUMATIC THAT
TRAUMATIC HISTORICAL EXPERIENCE
THAT HAS PLAGUED CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST PEOPLE WITH THE PASSAGE OF
PUBLIC LAW 280, THE STATE
ESSENTIALLY WASHED THEIR HANDS
OF POLICING TRIBAL RESERVATIONS
ON FEDERAL LANDS, ONE OF THE TOP
RECOMMENDATIONS OF TRIBAL GROUPS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND TRIBAL
LEADERS IS TO GRANT PEACE
OFFICER STATUS, AS OTHER STATES
IN THE UNITED STATES HAVE DONE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IS
CHAIRMAN JOE JAMES OF THE YUROK
TRIBE AND THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL AND GAGE HANSON WITH YUROK
TRIBAL COURT TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
YOU'LL HAVE TWO MINUTES. GAGE
HANSON, ASSOCIATE GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE YUROK TRIBE, THE
YUROK TRIBE SPONSORED THIS BILL,
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY IN THIS EFFORT.
THE YUROK TRIBE HAS ENTERED AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE COUNTIES OF
DEL NORTE AND HUMBOLDT TO
DEPUTIZE YUROK TRIBAL POLICE.
UNDER CALIFORNIA, EXISTING
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING LAWS. BUT
THAT IS SOLELY AT THE WHIM OF
THE LOCAL SHERIFFS. THAT COULD
GO AWAY AT ANY MOMENT. AND IT
DOESN'T REPRESENT A UNIFIED
POLICY OF CALIFORNIA SIMPLY
LOCALIZED WHIMS. AND THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT PROTECTS THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. THE YUROK
TRIBE'S RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
COUNTIES IS GOOD, BUT THAT
DOESN'T TRANSLATE TO TRIBES. ALL
ACROSS THE STATE AS, AS
REPRESENTATIVE RAMOS SAID,
PUBLIC LAW 280 WAS A BILL
PRESENTED BY CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS TO THE US CONGRESS
THAT ALLOWED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
REGULATE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY ON
RESERVATIONS BY NONMEMBERS AND
PUT THAT SOLELY ON THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THEN CALIFORNIA
WASHED ITS HANDS OF DOING NEARLY
ANYTHING ON TRIBAL RESERVATIONS
FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME.
AT THE SAME TIME, CALIFORNIA
PASSED LAWS THAT THE INDENTURED
INDIAN CHILDREN TO THE AGE OF
MAJORITY, WHICH AT THE TIME WAS
IN THE LATE 20S EARLY 30S. THIS
ACTIVITY OVER TIME CREATED A
PERIOD OF LAWLESSNESS ON
RESERVATIONS, ON THE PART OF THE
STATE, NOT OF TRIBES. TRIBAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS CONTINUED TO
MAINTAIN ITS TRADITIONAL ROOTS
FROM THE BEGINNING, OF TIME
IMMEMORIAL TO PRESENT. IT
ENFORCES THE LAWS OF THE TRIBE
AGAINST THE PEOPLE THAT HAS THE
JURISDICTION TO DO THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY, NONMEMBERS DON'T
APPLY. NONMEMBERS CAN CAN
PURCHASE, LAND ON RESERVATIONS.
THEY CAN THEY CAN CONDUCT
BUSINESS ON RESERVATIONS. AND
YET TRIBAL COURTS, TRIBAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT DO NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION TO GOVERN THEIR
ACTIVITIES. THANK YOU, DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER SPEAKER? YES,
MADAM CHAIR, WE HAVE CHAIRMAN
JOE JAMES OF THE YUROK TRIBAL
NATION. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
JOSEPH JAMES, CHAIRMAN OF THE
YUROK TRIBE. IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE FOSTER CARE BILL. AS GAGE
MENTIONED, A LITTLE HIGHLIGHTS
THERE. I'M I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE. I'M SORRY. SORRY. ON THE
RIGHT. BILL. THE PEACE OFFICER
STATUS BILL. THANK YOU. THAT IS
CORRECT. I SUPPORT FOSTER CARE
YOUTH TOO. SO I GOT UP REAL
EARLY THIS MORNING COMING FROM
CEREMONY DOWN HERE. SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE A LAW ENFORCEMENT, TRIBAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT UP THERE. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING IN COLLABORATION
WITH PARTNERSHIP WITH HUMBOLDT
AND DEL NORTE COUNTY, ADDRESSING
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT CRISIS AND
ALSO OUR IP CRISIS. THERE AND
AGAIN, THIS BILL GOES HAND IN
HAND COLLECTIVELY, WE'RE VERY
RURAL AND ISOLATED. THE NEED FOR
THE FOR THE PEACE OFFICER STATUS
FOR OUR TRIBAL POLICE IS MUCH
NEEDED. YOU KNOW, 20 YEARS WE
COULDN'T HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
WE WEREN'T THERE YET. WE'VE COME
A LONG WAY AND WE STILL GOT A
LONG WAY YET TO GO HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WITH OUR
TRIBAL POLICE AND GETTING THEM
PEACE OFFICER STATUS. BUT WE'RE
HERE TO SUPPORT THAT BILL. THIS
ADDRESSES A NUMBER OF THINGS ON
AND OFF THE RESERVATION. AND
THIS ALSO HIGHLIGHTS, IN YOUR
CASE, THE PARTNERSHIP THEY
CREATED WITH WHERE SHERIFF
HANSELL THERE WITH HUMBOLDT
COUNTY, WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TOO. AND AGAIN, WE ARE
HERE, FOR TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL TO NOT
ONLY HELP WITH OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTION, PUBLIC LAW 280,
BUT ALSO THE MÐI ÁP CRISIS THAT
WE'RE HAVING AT HOME IN REAL
TIME. AGAIN, APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TWO BILLS MIXED UP. I GOT UP
VERY EARLY THIS MORNING TO MAKE
THIS FIVE HOUR DRIVE. NO
WORRIES, SO IT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO BE HERE, AND
I'M SORRY I'M A LITTLE LATE, BUT
AGAIN, THANK YOU, THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES? LEAD OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO ME
TO STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION, WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. MADAM CHAIR
SCOTT. GOVERNOR, ON BEHALF OF
THE MORONGO BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OKAY. ANYBODY ELSE SEEING NONE.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, WE HAVE SENATOR SATO
THAT HAS MOVED THE BILL. I DO
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENT. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
IT VERY CLEAR. I SUPPORT THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
HISTORICALLY. WITHIN, YOU KNOW,
THE NEEDS OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES AND SO FORTH, ESPECIALLY
THE FEATHER ALERT. PREVIOUSLY, I
DO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AT
LEAST FOR ME, I AM CONCERNED. I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
REPRESENTATION FROM THE TRIBES
THAT DON'T HAVE FEDERAL
RECOGNITION. NUMBER ONE AND TWO,
SOME OF THE SMALLER TRIBES IN MY
DISTRICT, WE DO HAVE A SMALLER
TRIBE, THAT HAS BEEN STRUGGLING
TO GET SOME RECOGNITION AND SO
FORTH. SO I JUST WANT TO AT
LEAST BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
INCLUSIVE. SO I APPRECIATE, YOU
KNOW, THE EFFORT. AGAIN SENATOR
SKINNER, DID YOU HAVE ANYTHING?
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL.
THESE, THESE OBVIOUSLY ARE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN LONG TIME,
PROBLEMS THAT, I DON'T THINK THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD NECESSARILY
HAVE BEEN INSENSITIVE TO. BUT
NOT HAVING THE RELATIONSHIPS HAS
NOT BROUGHT FORWARD SOLUTIONS.
AND GIVEN WHERE, MANY OF OUR
TRIBES ARE LOCATED, THERE IS
REALLY VERY LITTLE OTHER, PEACE
OFFICER, OR SWORN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE AREA TO
ASSIST IN DEALING WITH THESE
ISSUES, LIKE OUR MISSING AND,
MISSING AND MURDERED,
INDIVIDUALS, TRIBAL INDIVIDUALS.
SO EXTENDING THIS ABILITY FOR
TRIBAL OFFICERS TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY ENFORCE THE LAW ON THE
LANDS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF OTHER
SUPPORT. SO, AND I, I SHARE THE
CHAIRS IN A WAY. I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IT IN EFFECT, BROADER, BUT I
REALIZE THAT IT'S THE BEGINNING,
SO IT'S OKAY. WE'LL START THIS
WAY. BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND AGAIN, I THINK WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO ECHO THAT THOSE TRIBES
THAT DON'T HAVE ALL THE
RESOURCES, YOU KNOW, SHOULD BE
AS YOU KNOW, BROUGHT TOGETHER
AND INCLUDED AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT. AND I WANT TO THANK JOE
JAMES, MAKING THE TRIP DOWN HERE
FROM CEREMONIAL AREAS THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE HERE TODAY,
REPRESENTING THE LARGEST TRIBE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. PL
280 IS A FEDERAL LAW. SO THAT
DEALS WITH THE FEDERAL COMPONENT
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE DO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
ON OTHER AREAS. AS FAR AS
EDUCATION. THAT ENCOMPASSES
EVERYONE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A BILL
THAT'S DRASTICALLY NEEDED TO
START MOVING FORWARD IN THE
HEALING AND THE PROTECTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE. I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SERRANO. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL?
VOTE SORRY. ITEM ITEM NUMBER
SIX, AB 2138. MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BILL I HAVE I SAY I SATO I
BRADFORD BRADFORD. I SKINNER.
SKINNER I WIENER WIENER I THAT
BILLS OUT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'D LIKE TO LIFT THE CALL ON
CONSENT. CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0.
WIENER WIENER. I ALL RIGHT
CONSENTS OUT. LET'S MOVE ON WITH
THE NEXT ITEMS. YES. OKAY ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB 1856. MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. SKINNER I, SKINNER I
WIENER WIENER I. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILLS OUT 4 TO 0 4 TO 0. SORRY.
ITEM 22 AB 2917. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE IS 3 TO 1. WIENER WIENER.
AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILLS OUT
AS WELL. ITEM 24 AB 3064. MOTION
WAS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 1 WIENER WIENER I 4 TO 1.
THAT BILLS OUT AS WELL. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS WHO WILL
BE PRESENTING FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB 1252. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS IN 2022, ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROB BONTA ESTABLISHED
THE OFFICE OF GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. AB 1252
CODIFIES THAT OFFICE INTO
STATUTE. ALSO ESTABLISHES A
COMMISSION TO END GUN VIOLENCE,
WHICH, UPON FURTHER
APPROPRIATION, WILL BE TASKED
WITH ISSUING A PUBLIC REPORT
IDENTIFYING TOP PRIORITIES TO
IMPROVE IMPLEMENTATION,
COORDINATION AND EFFECTIVENESS
OF GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
FOCUSED LAWS AND PROGRAMS.
CALIFORNIA HAS ENACTED MORE GUN
SAFETY LEGISLATION THAN ANY
OTHER STATE. AS A RESULT, WE
HAVE THE SEVENTH LOWEST GUN
DEATH RATE IN THE COUNTRY. WE
ALSO HAVE A HOMICIDE RATE THAT'S
33% LOWER THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE. THIS GUN SAFETY
LEGISLATION THAT WE HAVE ENACTED
ALSO ENSURES THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE ROBUST
AND EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION OF
OUR MANY VITAL LAWS AND PROGRAMS
. IN SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR,
PRESIDENT BIDEN ESTABLISHED THE
FIRST EVER WHITE HOUSE OFFICE OF
GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION. THE TOP
RECOMMENDATION OF THAT OFFICE.
THAT OFFICE IS SAFER STATES
AGENDA IS THAT EACH STATE
ESTABLISH THEIR OWN GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION OFFICE AS WELL
CREATION OF A COMPLEMENTARY
COMMISSION TO END GUN VIOLENCE
WILL FOSTER MORE COORDINATION
ACROSS DIFFERENT STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES AND CEMENT THE OFFICE'S CENTRAL ROLE
IN ADVISING POLICYMAKERS
RESPONSE TO THE VOTE. THANK YOU.
AND YOU HAVE NO WITNESSES,
CORRECT? NO. ALL RIGHT, I WILL
ASK FOR ANY LEAD SUPPORT. NONE.
LEAD OPPOSITION. NONE. ALL RIGHT
. METOOS NONE. GREAT, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON, SENATOR.
SPILL. ALL RIGHT. I DO REALLY
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I WAS
ACTUALLY AT THAT FIRST CONVENING
THAT THE, VICE PRESIDENT HELD,
AND IT IS THE LARGEST CONVENING
THAT THE BIDEN-HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION HAD ON RECORD SO
FAR. AND THIS IS VERY MUCH
NEEDED. SO I WILL ASK YOU TO
CLOSE, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER. ITEM
NUMBER THREE, AB 1252. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WAHAB Ã. WAHAB. AYE. SATO.
SATO. NO BRADFORD. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE WIENER. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL'S ON. CALL THE FASTEST BILL
I'VE EVER PRESENTED. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FLORA IS
GOING TO PRESENT ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT, AB 1892. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR AND COLLEAGUES, AB
1892 EXPANDS THE AUTHORITY OF
JUDGES TO ISSUE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO SEEK
COURT ORDERED AUTHORIZATION,
WIRETAPPING AND INTERCEPTION OF
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS
RELATED TO FELONY CHILD RELATED
CRIMES. THIS BILL GIVES LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES A GREATER
ABILITY TO INVESTIGATE AND
PROSECUTE THESE CRIMES AND
DISRUPT CHILD RINGS FASTER. THIS
BILL HAS NO NO VOTES AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES? I DON'T THINK SO. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO JUST DO
THIS FOR FORMALITIES, LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES SEEING NONE.
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES SEEING
NONE. ME TOO. SEEING NONE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. BILL, MOVE THE BILL HAS
BEEN DONE BY, SENATOR SATO.
SORRY. HE YOU KNOW, KIND OF
THREW ME OFF. INTRODUCE ME. OH,
MY GOSH, DID I MISS, WE MOVED
ON. BUT IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
WE HAVE A MOTION. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE. ALL
RIGHT, SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SATO. ITEM EIGHT, AB
1892, MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
FLOOR WILL HAVE. AYE. AYE. SATO.
SATO. AYE BRADFORD. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. WIENER WIENER.
AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL'S ON
CALL. THANK YOU. SENATORS
DEFINITELY. NOW WE DON'T HAVE.
ALL RIGHT, ASSEMBLY MEMBERS, IF
YOU GUYS WOULD LIKE TO COME DOWN
TO ROOM 2200, IF YOU DON'T LIKE,
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE A JOB TO DO.
IF STAFF IS HERE, PLEASE TEXT
YOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. I'M GOING
TO GO TO GO AND SEE IF WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM EVENTUALLY.
RIGHT OH THAT'S NICE. NO WORRIES
. THEY NEED THREE MORE, BUT IF I
CAN GET THERE AND THEN WE GET TO
, I'LL GET BACK HERE OR 2021
AND. YEAH MY SUGGESTION IS.
BECAUSE THE FIRST TIME. RIGHT.
YEAH.
WE'RE STARTING. THE SECOND. I
MEAN, I'M I'M. I'M I'M UP
THROUGH THE GROUND. I'M. I'M
FASTER. BUT IT'S NOT. BUT I
DON'T. ALL RIGHT, WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON
PRESENTING FILE NUMBER TWO, AB
628. MADAM CHAIR, SENATORS, I'M.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 628, A COMPANION BILL TO AK
EIGHT, A MEASURE THAT IF PASSED
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND APPROVED
BY VOTERS, WOULD REMOVE THE
EXCEPTION IN OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION THAT CURRENTLY
ALLOWS FOR INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE
CONTINGENT UPON THE PASSAGE AND
APPROVAL OF AK EIGHT. AB 628
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION, ALSO KNOWN AS
CDCR, TO CREATE A VOLUNTARY WORK
PROGRAM. FURTHER, IT CLARIFIES
THAT CDCR AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SET COMPENSATION
FOR INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS IN
STATE PRISON FACILITIES AND
LOCAL JAILS, RESPECTIVELY. THIS
MEASURE.
THIS MEASURE WOULD ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE TO AMEND ARTICLE ONE,
SECTION SIX OF THE STATE
CONSTITUTION TO PROHIBIT SLAVERY
AND INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE
WITHOUT EXCEPTION, IF AK EIGHT
IS APPROVED BY VOTERS, IT WILL
END THE PRACTICE OF INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE, WHICH IS THE RULE
THAT HAVE ALLOWED CALIFORNIA
STATE PRISON TO USE FORCED LABOR
. MADAM CHAIR, IF YOU COULD HAVE
ME FOR PERSONAL PRIVILEGE TO
TAKE A MOMENT. YES. YESTERDAY,
IN OUR OFFICE, WE LOST A FORMER
FELLOW NAMED ALDO GARCIA, WHO
WAS EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO WORK
ON AC EIGHT AS THE PINNACLE OF
HIS EARLY CAREER AND JUST
MOMENTS AGO, WE WERE REMINDED OF
THAT BEFORE COMING IN HERE. SO I
EMOTIONS IS THIS IS A POWERFUL,
HISTORIC MOMENT FOR OUR STATE.
AND KNOWING THAT A YOUNG LIFE
WAS LOST, WHO COULD BE SHARING
IN THE REVELRY OF THIS BILL
PASSING? ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. NOW BY REMOVING THE
LONG STANDING EXCEPTION FOR
PUNISHMENT OF A CRIME AND
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITING SLAVERY
AND INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE, IT
WOULD FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
NATURE OF WORK WITHIN OUR STATE
PRISONS. FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
OUR STATE HISTORY, THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE WORK
ASSIGNMENTS FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS TO BE VOLUNTARY, AND
THEY WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT TO
DISCIPLINE FOR REFUSING A WORK
ASSIGNMENT, ALLOWING FOR GRANTED
PARTICIPATION IN REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES AND HELPING TO RESTORE
DIGNITY AND BODILY AUTONOMY TO
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS.
INCARCERATED PEOPLE HAVE LONG
FACED CRUEL TREATMENT FOR ANY
WORK ABSENCES. THIS INCLUDES
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT, DENIAL OF
PHONE CALLS AND FAMILY VISITS,
AND LIMITING PARTICIPATION IN
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AND
DISCIPLINARY WRITE UPS THAT
RESULT IN LONGER PRISON TERMS,
SUCH PUNISHMENT OR THREATS OF
SUCH PUNISHMENTS ARE OFTEN
ISSUED EVEN WHEN ABSENCES ARE
DUE TO ILLNESS OR INJURIES
SUSTAINED THROUGH WORK. THE
CURRENT PRACTICE OF FORCED LABOR
DOES NOT PREPARE INCARCERATED
PEOPLE FOR SUCCESS. UPON
REENTRY, AND OFTEN PREVENTS
PARTICIPATION IN REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES. THIS BILL CLARIFIES
IMPLEMENTATION OF ACA EIGHT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION. WITH THAT,
I'LL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE BECAUSE WE DO NOT HAVE
WITNESSES TODAY. OKAY SO WE HAVE
NO LEAD WITNESSES. DO WE HAVE
LEAD OPPOSITION? ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ME TO
STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION, WHETHER OR NOT YOU
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, GLENN
BACKUS FOR THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS KATINA
PERRY. I'M WITH IT'S NOT OKAY
MOMS FOR CHANGE. AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
SHIRVAN NIZAMI INITIATED JUSTICE
ACTION IN SUPPORT. RUTH'S THE
LADY CONCERNED CITIZEN AND
STRONG SUPPORT. ALICIA MONTEIRO,
WHICH IS ADVOCATING STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NAME IS CARRIE
ARZATE. I'M SYSTEM IMPACTED AND
I HAVE A COUPLE OF METOOS AS
WELL. EMPOWERING WOMEN IMPACTED
BY INCARCERATION, FELONY
ELIMINATION, MURDER PROJECT IJ
MEMBER I'M A MEMBER OF IJ
ACTION, AND I'M ALSO AN OUTSIDE
ORGANIZER WITH INITIATE JUSTICE
AND PRISON FROM THE INSIDE OUT.
AND I THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. CAN WE
HAVE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER, COME
FORWARD JUST SO WE HAVE IT LINED
UP. SERGEANTS, IF YOU GUYS WOULD
LIKE TO TELL HER THAT. ALL
RIGHT. CONTINUE WITH THE METOOS,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING, YOLANDA
NAVARETTE ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE, INITIATE JUSTICE
ACTION, FELONY MURDER
ELIMINATION PROJECT AND FAMILIES
UNITED TO END LOOP AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LESLIE
CALDWELL, HOUSTON, FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. MICHELLE
GILES. CONCERNED CITIZEN STRONG
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
OTHER SPEAKERS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. OH GO AHEAD. VÌ
ROCHELLE, CONCERNED CITIZEN AND
ALSO WITH SC JUSTICE. AND I'M IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY KATRINA
REECE WITH INITIATE JUSTICE AND
STRONG SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. NO
OTHER METOOS. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SENATOR SERRANO, A
QUESTION ABOUT FUNDING FOR THIS.
WHERE DO YOU PROPOSE THE FUNDING
WOULD COME FROM? SO THIS, THIS
PARTICULAR FUNDING, I MEAN, THIS
PARTICULAR BILL DOESN'T REQUIRE
FUNDING IN THAT TRADITIONAL
SENSE OF THE TERM. IT DOES
NOTHING TO CHANGE THE CURRENT
PROGRAM. IT JUST MAKES IT FROM
FROM CHAU TO VOLUNTARY SO THAT
HAS NO REAL DIRECT IMPACT ON, I
THINK WHEN IT COMES TO FUNDING.
SO DOESN'T HAVE A MINIMUM WAGE
AND NO, IT DOES NOT ADDRESS
WAGES IN ANY WAY. AND IT ALSO
NOTES WITHIN THE SECTION THAT IT
DOES NOT ADDRESS MINIMUM WAGE.
SO THAT WOULD BE A SEPARATE THAT
WOULD HAVE TO BE A SEPARATE
BILL. IT DOES DIRECT IT THAT A
MINIMUM WAGE UNLESS, LET ME GO
SPECIFICALLY TO THAT LANGUAGE.
BUT IT, IT SPEAKS TO THAT IT, IT
DIRECTS THE MINIMUM WAGE TO BE
SET BY STATE LAW OR LOCAL
ORDINANCE AS IT RELATES TO
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS, AND
THAT OTHERWISE THE COMPENSATION
IS SET BY THE SECRETARY OR
LOCAL, LOCALS WHEN IT COMES TO
THEIR COUNTY OR CITY JAILS. AND
SO IF THE MINIMUM WAGE IS WHAT
IT IS TODAY, THEN IT HAS NO
IMPACT. THERE'S NO COST TO THE
STATE IN ANY ADDITIONAL WAY, BUT
THEY DO SET THE REST OF THE
COMPENSATION, WHICH IS, YOU
KNOW, WAGE IS A COMPONENT OF
COMPENSATION. AND SO THEY SET
THAT UNLESS, UNLESS THE STATE
SPEAKS TO IT. AND RIGHT NOW THE
STATE IS SILENT ON THAT SUBJECT.
AND THERE IS A STUDY BILL, THAT
WAS PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARTER. BUT THERE HAS BEEN NO
CHANGE TO WAGES AS IT RELATES TO
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. OKAY.
WERE THERE ANY STUDIES DONE TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH PARTICIPATION
THEY MIGHT HAVE FOR VOLUNTARY
WORK VERSUS WORK? THAT'S
ASSIGNED AND PAID A MINIMUM WAGE
OR WHATEVER? SAY THAT AGAIN. IN
OTHER WORDS, WOULD THEY HAVE ANY
VOLUNTARY WORK? I MEAN, WOULD
PEOPLE VOLUNTEER TO WORK OR
WOULD THEY HAVE TO FIND SOMEBODY
SOMETHING, SOME OTHER WAY OF
PAYING FOR THAT, LIKE HIRING
CIVILIANS TO COME IN AND WORK
AND THEREBY INCREASING THE COST
OF RUNNING THE PRISON? YEAH. SO
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK PROGRAMS
AND SOME RELATE TO THE
OPERATIONS OF THE PRISON AND
SOME DO NOT, IN THIS REGARD, THE
INCENTIVES ARE RIGHT. THEY
CURRENTLY USE LIKE EARLY, THE
CREDIT EARLY RELEASE. YEAH.
THOSE TYPE OF, THOSE ARE THE
TYPES OF, INCENTIVES THAT THEY
USE RELATED TO WORK. AND SO LIKE
I SAID, THIS BILL JUST MOVES IT
FROM A REQUIREMENT TO VOLUNTARY
WHAT IT SPECIFICALLY IS INTENDED
TO DO IS RIGHT NOW BECAUSE,
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE WITHIN OUR
CONSTITUTION HAS THAT EXCEPTION
FOR PUNISHMENT OF A CRIME. IT
ALLOWS GREAT LATITUDE FOR CDCR
TO PRIORITIZE WORKING, WHICH IS
CURRENTLY DONE IN SECTION 27
OVER REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS OR
OVER BEING SICK AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE. SO WHAT THIS REALLY
DOES IS REVERSES THAT. IT MAKES
IT VOLUNTARY. AND SO I THINK
CDCR STILL MAINTAINS FULL
CONTROL FOR THE OPERATIONS OF
THEIR PRISON. AND THEY CAN THEY
GET THE AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP A PROGRAM THAT ADDRESSES
WHATEVER THOSE NEEDS ARE, TO
KEEP A HEALTHY AND SAFE
OPERATION OF A PRISON. I
UNDERSTOOD I'M JUST KIND OF A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT, HOW YOU
DETERMINE WHETHER SOMEBODY IS
VOLUNTARY. I MEAN, THERE'S A LOT
OF THINGS THAT ARE VOLUNTARY,
RIGHT? AND A LOT OF PEOPLE CALL
IT BEING VOLUNTOLD AND HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO DIFFERENTIATE
AND WHAT THAT LEADS TO. IF IF
YOU'RE IF THERE IS A DISPUTE
ABOUT WHETHER, HEY, THEY'RE
MAKING ME DO THIS OR NOT,
WHETHER THAT BECOMES A VIOLATION
THAT WE WIND UP HAVING TO PAY
FOR THROUGH A CIVIL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. SO WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT ONE CDCR HAS, YOU KNOW,
WIDE LATITUDE TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS THAT THEY
MAY HAVE. AND OUR BILL, ALLOWS
THAT TO HAPPEN. SECONDLY, I
WOULD SAY THAT THERE ARE WAY
MORE, INCARCERATED PERSONS THAN
THERE ARE ACTUALLY WORK. RIGHT.
AND SO IF AN INMATE OR
INCARCERATED PERSON HAS, FEELS
THAT THEY DO NOT WANT TO DO
THAT, PARTICULARLY THERE IS
SOMEONE ELSE WHO MAY BE WILLING
TO. AND SO I DON'T THINK WE'LL
RUN INTO THAT ISSUE. IT WOULD BE
DIFFERENT IF IT WAS OVER.
SUBSCRIBED OR PRESCRIBED
PROGRAM. BUT IT IS IT IS NOT.
AND SO I THINK THAT, I THINK
THAT THAT WILL BE ABLE TO BE
ADDRESSED BY CDCR AND WE GIVE
THEM THE LATITUDE TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT. WE DO NOT HINDER
THEM IN ANY WAY, WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN OF
CONCERN. AND TALK ABOUT HOW MUCH
CONTROL TO GIVE TO CDCR. BUT WE
ALLOWED THEM TO MAINTAIN
DISCRETION AMONG WHAT A
VOLUNTARY WORK PROGRAM LOOKS
LIKE AS LONG AS THEY DON'T
VENTURE INTO SLAVERY IN ANY
FORM, WHICH RESULTS IN
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE, FORCED
LABOR, INDENTURED SERVITUDE,
THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
UNDERSTOOD. AND I UNDERSTAND ALL
OF THOSE CONCERNS. AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE WELL-FOUNDED. MY CONCERN
IS THAT WE ALREADY ARE TAKING A
SYSTEM. THE REHABILITATION
SYSTEM, AND STRAINING IT ALREADY
WITH CUTS. AND YET WE'RE LOOKING
AT PROGRAMS THAT HAVE A HUGE
POTENTIAL TO INCREASE COSTS AND
WITHIN THE PRISON. SO YEAH, THAT
THAT'S MY CONCERN ABOUT THIS
BILL AND OTHERS UNTIL WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A BETTER PLAN FOR
CDCR OVERALL, THAT INCLUDES ALL
OF THE ABOVE, AND WE HAVE THE
FUNDING NECESSARY TO DO IT, I'M
A LITTLE LEERY ABOUT ADDING ON
TO THOSE COSTS. THANK YOU. YEAH.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE? ALL RIGHT. I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT UNTIL WE
ACTUALLY PUSH FOR CHANGE, WHICH
I APPRECIATE YOU TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS, BILL, WE'RE NOT GOING
TO SEE CHANGE. AND WE KNOW THAT
ESPECIALLY WITH SYSTEMIC ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN, LASTING FOR
DECADES, IF NOT CENTURIES. SO
THANK YOU FOR THIS TIMELY
EFFORT. ASSEMBLY SENATOR SKINNER
, GET MOVED. YEAH I DIDN'T WANT
TO CUT, YOU KNOW, GO AHEAD. IT'S
FINE, I WILL MOVE THE BILL. I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. I THINK THAT THE FACT
THAT THIS IS IN OUR CONSTITUTION
IS ABHORRENT AND THAT WE SHOULD
GET RID OF IT. I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST BE ABLE TO GET RID OF IT IN
OUR CONSTITUTION IN A CLEAN WAY.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THAT THERE
ARE OTHER CONSIDERATIONS THAT
HAVE, COME FORWARD TO, THAT
MIGHT MAKE THAT MORE DIFFICULT,
BUT I THINK, JUST ON THE FACE OF
IT, CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT HAVE
IN ITS CONSTITUTION THE ABILITY
TO ENSLAVE ANYONE. SO I SUPPORT
THE BILL, BUT AGAIN, I THINK IT
WOULD BE GREAT IF WE COULD DO
IT. JUST ELIMINATE IT. ANYWAY, I
WANT TO ADD THAT I KNOW THAT
THIS HAS BEEN ATTEMPTED BEFORE,
AND OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE NOT SEEN
IT ACTUALLY MOVE ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE, SO I'M HOPING THAT
THIS WILL BE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT, I DO JUST WANT TO
RECOMMEND FOR YOU IS THAT WHEN
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT IT WITH
OTHER MEMBERS AS IT MOVES ALONG,
IS THAT MAKING IT MAKING IT VERY
CLEAR WHAT IS ALLOWED AFTER THIS
BILL WOULD PASS, THE FACT THAT,
YOU KNOW, WHEN WE GO TO NORWAY
AND WE TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
DEVELOPING GOOD NEIGHBORS, WE
TALK ABOUT THEM HAVING THE
OPTIONS OF EITHER WORKING OR
EDUCATING THEMSELVES. AND SO
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE THE
QUESTION, SO WHAT DO THEY DO?
RIGHT SO WITH THAT, I'LL ASK YOU
TO CLOSE AND WE CAN HAVE A VOTE.
THANK YOU, AND SO I APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION AND THE CONCERNS.
AND AS THIS BILL HAS NAVIGATED,
OVER THE LAST 18 MONTHS THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION, WE'VE
SOUGHT TO ADDRESS THOSE TYPE OF
CONCERNS, INCLUDING,
CONGRESSWOMAN. NOW,
CONGRESSWOMAN KAMLAGER DOVE DID
THE SAME THING WHEN SHE HAD
PRESENTED THIS IN THE PREVIOUS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. AND SO WHAT
WE HAVE ATTEMPTED TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE OUR VALUE
STATEMENT AND OUR CONSTITUTION
CORRECTLY. THAT REMOVES,
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE,
EXCEPTION. AND THEN AT THE SAME
TIME, CREATE A COMPANION BILL
THAT ACTUALLY REMOVES THAT TYPE
OF LANGUAGE, WHICH IS A
REQUIREMENT LANGUAGE TO WORK, IT
WOULD, OUT OF THE SECTIONS AS IT
RELATES TO HOW CDCR OPERATES AND
THEN ALSO PUTTING GUARDRAILS
AROUND THEIR ABILITY TO OPERATE
A HEALTH, A HEALTHY AND SAFE
PRISON, AND I THINK WE'VE STRUCK
THAT BALANCE IN THIS COMPANION
BILL, THIS COMPANION BILL WOULD
NOT GO FORWARD IF, FOR WHATEVER
REASON, AK EIGHT, IT FAILS AT
THE BALLOT BOX, I LOOK FORWARD
TO THE CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSIONS AS WE NAVIGATE THE
REST OF THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
OVER THE OVER A DAY AS WE HIT
TOWARDS THE DEADLINE, AND
TALKING WITH MY COLLEAGUES, TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO MAKE
A STRONG VALUE STATEMENT AND AT
THE SAME TIME DO WHAT'S
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT OUR
PRISONS OPERATE IN A HEALTH AND
SAFETY, HEALTH AND SAFE MANNER.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SKINNER. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL?
VOTE, PLEASE. ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
628. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB I, WAHAB I
SATO. SATO. NO. BRADFORD.
SKINNER. SKINNER I WIENER. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES,
PLEASE, WHO WILL BE PRESENTING
FILE NUMBER 15 AB 20 308. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR. TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB 2308. I FIRST WANT
TO THANK COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS MEASURE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND OTHER
SEXUAL OFFENSES CAN PETITION A
COURT FOR A PROTECTIVE ORDER
FROM THEIR ABUSER. THESE ORDERS
USUALLY LAST AROUND TEN YEARS.
HOWEVER, DATA SHOWED THAT
UNFORTUNATELY, DURING AND AFTER
THE PANDEMIC, THERE HAS BEEN A
RISE IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES,
ACCORDING TO HARVARD GAZETTE
FILING. DOMESTIC FILING CASES IN
2021 AND 2022 ROSE BETWEEN 25
AND 33, DEPENDING ON THE
SEVERITY OF THE CASE. MEMBERS AB
2308 IS A COMMON SENSE AND
NARROW MEASURE TO INCREASE THE
TIME AMOUNT OF PROTECTIVE FROM
10 TO 15 YEARS. IN THE CASE OF
THE WORST TYPE OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENT CRIME, THE ONES THAT
INVOLVE CORPORAL INJURY AND
LEAVES THE VICTIM IN A TRAUMATIC
CONDITION. THESE ARE VICTIMS
THAT ARE PHYSICALLY BEATEN SO
SEVERELY THEY REQUIRE IMMEDIATE
MEDICAL ATTENTION AND OFTENTIMES
REQUIRE STAYS IN HOSPITALS.
WHILE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS
MAY NOT SEEM LIKE A LOT, THIS IS
A VALUABLE TIME OF VICTIM CAN
USE TO RECOVER FROM THEIR
TRAUMA, AS WELL AS RAISE THEIR
CHILDREN AWAY FROM A PARTNER OR
SPOUSE WHO POSES AN IMMEDIATE
THREAT TO THEM. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE CONFERENCE OF
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATION AND
HAS SUPPORT FROM MAJOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS, AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO
END DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. WITH ME
HERE TO TESTIFY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IS MICHAEL FERN FROM
THE CCPA ON BEHALF OF THE
VICTIMS WHO CANNOT BE HERE
TODAY, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TWO MINUTES. ALL
RIGHT. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL FERN, AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CONFERENCE OF
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATIONS,
WHICH IS THE SPONSOR OF AB 2308.
AB TWO 3008 HELPS ADDRESS THE
DISCONNECT BETWEEN A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER
ISSUED BY A FAMILY COURT, WHICH
CAN ISSUE A PERMANENT ORDER
VERSUS A RESTRAINING ORDER
ISSUED BY A CRIMINAL COURT
FOLLOWING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CONVICTION PURSUANT TO 23.5,
WHICH IS CAPPED AT NO MORE THAN
TEN YEARS AND CANNOT BE RENEWED
REGARDLESS OF THE FACTS. UNLIKE
FAMILY COURT, A CRIMINAL COURT
AFFORDS DEFENDANTS SIGNIFICANTLY
GREATER DUE PROCESS PROTECTIONS,
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO COUNSEL,
THE RIGHT TO TRIAL BY JURY, AND
THE RIGHT TO HAVE ANY CHARGES
PROVEN BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT, BEYOND REASONABLE DOUBT
BY A JURY, THESE RIGHTS DON'T
EXIST FOR CIVIL DEFENDANTS WHO,
AGAIN, CAN OBTAIN PERMANENT
ORDERS IN FAMILY COURT, AND ALSO
DEFENDANTS IN FAMILY COURT MUST
HIRE AN ATTORNEY AND CANNOT GET
ONE OR MUST REPRESENT THEMSELVES
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS
WHO PARTICIPATE IN CRIMINAL CASE
ALL THE WAY THROUGH CONVICTION,
WHOSE SITUATIONS AND UNIQUE FACT
PATTERNS WARRANT A COURT FINDING
A RESTRAINING ORDER BEYOND TEN
YEARS. THESE SURVIVORS MUST
FILE, UNDER CURRENT LAW, A
RESTRAINING ORDER ON THEIR OWN
IN CIVIL COURT AGAINST THE
DEFENDANT SUING AND SERVING THEM
ON THEIR OWN. AND THIS POSES
IMPOSES UNNECESSARY RISKS, COSTS
AND BURDENS TO EVERYONE, AS
AMENDED, AB 2308 WOULD ALLOW
CRIMINAL COURT TO ISSUE A DV
RESTRAINING ORDER THAT CAN LAST
UP TO 15 YEARS, INSTEAD OF TEN
YEARS, WHEN A COURT AGAIN FINDS
THAT A LONGER DURATION IS
WARRANTED BY THE FACTUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. WHILE THIS
DOESN'T FULLY RESOLVE THE
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN CIVIL COURTS
AND CRIMINAL COURTS, IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD THAT
WILL SAVE JUDICIAL RESOURCES,
PROVIDE FOR GREATER PEACE OF
MIND, AND IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY
OUTCOMES. I JUST WANT TO END
WITH A QUOTE FROM PROFESSOR JANE
STOVER, WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DV CLINIC AT UC IRVINE
SCHOOL OF LAW FROM HER LAW
REVIEW ARTICLE ENTITLED
ENJOINING ABUSE THE CASE FOR
INDEFINITE DV PROTECTION ORDERS,
SHE NOTED THE FOLLOWING QUOTE.
SOCIAL SCIENTISTS HAVE FOUND
THAT LENGTHIER ORDERS PRODUCE
MORE SUBSTANTIAL SAFETY
OUTCOMES. MULTIPLE STUDIES HAVE
NOW FOUND A CORRELATION BETWEEN
THE DURATION OF THE PROTECTIVE
ORDER AND THE SURVIVORS SAFETY,
WHICH RESEARCHERS HAVE DESCRIBED
AS A DOSE RESPONSE RELATIONSHIP.
ACCORDING TO THE DURATION OF THE
CIVIL PROTECTION ORDER.
MAINTAINING THE COURTS
PROTECTION OVER TIME IS KEY.
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES? SEEING NONE, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. SEEING
NONE, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ME TO STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR ORG,
AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT. LET'S
LET'S SPEED IT UP, GUYS. GARRETT
HAMILTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION,
WE SUPPORT ERIC HENDERSON ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS UNITED
FOR A RESPONSIBLE BUDGET. CURB
IN OPPOSITION. Dð COONEY ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN OPPOSITION. LESLIE CALDWELL,
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. I
JUST WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR WE
HAVE WITHDRAWN OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. COREY SOLO, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO OTHER
SPEAKERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, SENATOR
SERRANO MOVES THE BILL. SENATOR
SKINNER QUESTION. THIS INCLUDES
THE AMENDMENT FOR THE
DISCRETIONARY HEARING. THERE'S
NO AMENDMENT. THERE'S NO
AMENDMENTS ON THIS BILL. OKAY.
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT THE CJ
WANTS. Þ, OKAY. OKAY. I DIDN'T
REALIZE WHETHER THERE WAS OR
NOT. IT WAS IN MY NOTES. OKAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY
CLARIFYING COMMENTS, MR. FERRER?
YES, SO I WAS MADE AWARE THAT
THERE MAY BE A REQUEST, BY AN
ENTITY TO EXPRESSLY INCLUDE
WITHIN THE LAW THE ABILITY TO
TERMINATE OR MODIFY AN ORDER OR
PROTECTIVE ORDER. I CAN SAY WITH
CERTAINTY, BECAUSE I'VE SEEN IT,
THAT THAT ALREADY EXISTS AS A
MATTER OF COURSE, WITHIN THE
COURT COURT'S OWN, INHERENT
POWERS. THEY CAN ASSURE THAT
ISSUES AND ORDER CAN ALWAYS
MODIFY IT, CAN TERMINATE IT
EITHER SIDE, WHETHER IT'S THE
PERSON BRINGING THE ORDER, THE
DA'S OFFICE THAT BROUGHT THE
ORDER OR OBTAINED THE ORDER, OR
EVEN THE DEFENDANT, THAT'S UNDER
THE ORDER, THEY CAN APPEAR IN
COURT TO ASK THAT IT BE REMOVED
OR, OR OR MODIFIED. THE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENT, THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE, IF THAT'S THE
ISSUE, SO NUMBER ONE, I THINK
THAT THERE IS A SLIGHT
DISAGREEMENT ON THAT. I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT AND YOU
DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER ANY
FURTHER. BUT, WE WOULD LIKE A
CLARIFYING AMENDMENT AS THIS
MOVES FORWARD TO A PROCESS. AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT YOU WOULD TAKE
THAT VERY CLEAR AMENDMENT, IT
CERTAINLY WILL. OKAY. AND WE
HAVE COMMITMENT FROM THE AUTHOR.
AND OUR COMMITTEE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU. AND AGAIN, WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR SARDO.
SENATOR SKINNER, DID YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS? ALL RIGHT.
SEEING THAT YOU HAVE AND WILL
TAKE THE AMENDMENT, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
YEAH, WE SET UP. WE CAN DO IT.
ITEM 15 AB 2308. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB
I SATO. SATO I BRADFORD.
SKINNER. SKINNER I WIENER. ALL
RIGHT, SO THAT BILL IS ON CALL,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER. KHN WHO
WILL BE PRESENTING TWO BILLS,
BUT SHE WILL START WITH FILE
ITEM TEN AB 2021. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2021. THIS
IS A BILL THAT CAME OUT OF A
CONVERSATION I WAS HAVING WITH
TEENAGERS IN MY OWN COMMUNITY
WHO WERE DESCRIBING HOW MANY
KIDS WERE USING THE NEW TOBACCO
PRODUCTS IN WHICH, FOR THOSE
THAT DON'T KNOW, IS A TOBACCO
PRODUCT YOU PLACE UNDER YOUR
LIP. IT'S THE NEW CHEW IT
DISSOLVES. IT IS FULL OF
TOBACCO. OBVIOUSLY ADDICTIVE AND
CARCINOGENIC. AND I WAS
PERPLEXED. HOW DID ALL OF THESE
KIDS HAVE ACCESS TO THIS TOBACCO
PRODUCT, WHICH, BY THE WAY, IS
FLAVORED IN CALIFORNIA. ALL OF
THAT SEEMED TO BE AGAINST THE
LAW. AND WHAT WE STARTED TO
LEARN UPON RESEARCHING THIS WAS
THAT THE COST OF THE FINES, IF
YOU SELL TO YOUTH, ARE SO MINOR
IN THE LAW RIGHT NOW, $200 THAT
IT IS JUST THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS. AND SO OUR LOCAL
STORES ARE SELLING TO MINORS,
ADDICTING THEM, AND THEY ARE
BEING HARMED. AND SO THIS BILL
IS VERY SIMPLE. IT RAISES THE
FINES SO THAT IT IS NO LONGER
THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS TO
CAUSE ADDICTION AND HARM TO OUR
CHILDREN. WITH ME HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IS TAMMY
DILLON, A LOCAL PRINCIPAL FOR
LIBERTY HIGH CONTINUATION HIGH
SCHOOL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS TAMMY
DILLON. I'VE BEEN AN EDUCATION
AND PUBLIC EDUCATION FOR 40
YEARS, SITE ADMINISTRATOR FOR 31
YEARS, THE LAST 13 YEARS AS A
SCHOOL SITE PRINCIPAL. AND I
HAVE SEEN AN INCREDIBLE INCREASE
IN STUDENTS WHO ARE VAPING AND
TOBACCO USE WITHIN THE SCHOOLS,
BEFORE COMING HERE, I CONTACTED
MY COLLEAGUES AND THEY ARE
SEEING THE SAME THING THEY SAID,
NO LONGER IS THE ISSUE FIGHTING,
NO LONGER IS THE ISSUE GANGS.
IT'S DRUG USE, IT'S TOBACCO USE.
IT'S PREVALENT IN THE BATHROOM.
STUDENTS MEET 15 TO 20 KIDS AT A
TIME. SO KIDS WHO WANT TO USE
THE BATHROOMS OFTEN CAN'T GET IN
THERE. AT LODI HIGH SCHOOL ALONE
FIRST SEMESTER, THE SMOKE
DETECTOR WENT OFF 40 TIMES IN
THE SEMESTER. ONE DAY IT WENT
OFF FOUR TIMES IN ONE DAY, WHICH
MEANS THE ENTIRE SCHOOL HAS TO
BE EVACUATED, WHICH AFFECTS
TESTING, WHICH AFFECTS ALL KINDS
OF THINGS THAT HAVE A DOMINO
RIPPLE EFFECT THAT IS NEGATIVE
FOR STUDENTS. NATIONAL DISEASE
CENTER FOR CONTROL SAYS THAT
TOBACCO IS THE NUMBER ONE
CONTRIBUTOR FOR PREVENTABLE
DISEASES. AND WE'RE HAVING
STUDENTS AT THE MIDDLE SCHOOL
LEVEL AGES 12 AND 13, IT HAS
INCREASED ABOUT 500. THE
SUSPENSIONS THAT ARE HAPPENING
FOR TOBACCO AND VAPE RELATED
ISSUES. IT HAS PREVALENT WITHIN
THE SCHOOLS, AND IT IS BECOME A
VERY BIG ISSUE REGARDING WITH
ADDICTIONS FOR OUR KIDS. WE'RE
SEEING ANXIETY LEVELS GO UP, ALL
KINDS OF REPERCUSSIONS THAT COME
FROM TOBACCO USE, AND IT IS VERY
EASY TO GET IN. I REMEMBER 15
YEARS AGO, 20 YEARS AGO. ABC
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL USED
TO DO STING OPERATIONS FOR
PLACES THAT SOLD ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. THERE IS NO NOTHING
THAT HAPPENS NOW, IN THE PAST,
THOSE PLACES OF ESTABLISHED,
THOSE BUSINESSES WERE GIVEN KIND
OF A, A FROWN BY THE LOCAL
ADULTS SEEING THAT THEY WERE
SELLING TO, TO MINORS. NOW
THAT'S NOTHING. IT'S NOTHING FOR
TOBACCO USE. AND TOBACCO BUYS
FOR MINORS TO BE HAPPENING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES SEEING
NONE. LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
SEEING NONE. ME. TWOS. GARRETT
HAMILTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
WE SUPPORT JOE SIGNS WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
SPEAKERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO COMMITTEE MEMBER, SENATOR
SIERRA. I KNOW YOU WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING. I HAVE A QUESTION.
YEAH DO WE DO STUDIES ON WHERE A
MAJORITY OF THESE KIDS ARE
GETTING THEIR TOBACCO SINCE IT
IS DIFFICULT IF THEY GO INTO A
STORE, MOST OF THE STORES I SEE,
DO CARD OR REQUIRE SOME ID, WHAT
HAPPENS IS THE 25 YEAR OLD WHO
DECIDES TO MAKE A BUSINESS, GOES
IN AND BUYS UP A BUNCH OF THIS
STUFF, AND THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
ACTUALLY SELL IT TO THESE KIDS
IN HIGH SCHOOL. BUT THERE'S
NOTHING HERE FOR THEM. WHAT ARE
WE DOING ABOUT THAT PART OF IT?
BECAUSE THAT'S THE MAJORITY PART
OF IT. I DON'T THINK HAMMERING
BUSINESSES AND CORPORATIONS,
WITH THE KNOW OR SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN CLAUSE IS ACTUALLY GOING
TO MAKE A DENT IN THIS PROBLEM.
AND IN FACT, IT WILL MAKE THE
CURRENT SITUATION EVEN WORSE
WHERE YOU HAVE INDIVIDUALS GOING
OUT. AND NOT ONLY THAT, BUT
THEY'RE THEY'RE BUYING IT FOR
WHATEVER IT COSTS IN THE STORE.
THEY GOT TO MAKE A MARK UP. SO
THEY GO OUT AND THEY SELL IT FOR
EVEN MORE. AND BECAUSE THE KIDS
KNOW THAT THEY SHOULDN'T BE
BUYING IT, AND IF THEY GO TO THE
STORE, WHAT HAPPENS? I MEAN,
WHERE ARE WE DOING TO TAKE CARE
OF THAT PART OF IT? SO I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT TO YOUR
POINT OF THE BUSINESSES YOU GO
INTO THAT ARE RESPONSIBLY
CARDING, THAT'S A COMPLETE
DEFENSE TO THIS. SO THOSE FOLKS
WOULD OBVIOUSLY NOT BE HAMMERED,
WHICH IS ALL WE ASK OF FOLKS IS
TO CARD INDIVIDUALS AND ENSURE
THEY'RE OF MAJORITY AGE. AND I
HAVE TO SAY, THIS IS I AM NOT BY
ANY MEANS SOMEBODY WHO SAYS THAT
I HAVE EVERY SOLUTION TO EVERY
PROBLEM. THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. IF YOU HAVE A
BILL TO ADDRESS THE SECONDARY
PROBLEM, I'D HAPPILY SUPPORT
THAT. SENATOR. NO, BECAUSE THAT
WOULD, THAT WOULD THAT WOULD
INVOLVE HAVING AN INDIVIDUAL BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY HERE IS NOT GOING
TO PRISON OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
NOT GETTING ARRESTED, NOT HAVING
A RECORD. ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
SO WE DON'T WE'RE NOT GOING TO
REEL THAT IN AND WE'RE GOING TO
GO AFTER CORPORATIONS,
BUSINESSES, RETAILERS OR
WHOLESALERS DOING A KNOWN OR
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN CLAUSE THAT IS
ACTUALLY PART OF OUR PROBLEMS
TOO, THAT PEOPLE LOOK FOR THOSE
AND THEY TURN INTO LAWSUITS AND
THEY AND, AND THAT INCREASES THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS, WHICH
INCREASES THE COST TO ALL OF US.
THIS BILL IS GOING AFTER THE
WRONG PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE CAUSING THE PROBLEM THAT
THIS PRINCIPAL IS TALKING ABOUT
ARE THEIR PEERS AND THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ATTACHED TO THAT HAVE
THE THAT ARE OLDER, THAT ARE
BUYING THIS AND THEN RESELLING
IT FOR A MARKUP PRICE. SO,
BECAUSE OF THAT, I'M NOT GOING
TO BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL. THEY
ALREADY HAVE FINES IN PLACE,
BUT, BUT IF WE WANT TO DO
INDIVIDUALS, I WOULD BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN. BILLS
THAT WOULD DO THAT. I JUST DON'T
WANT TO WASTE MY TIME. THANK
YOU, SENATOR, THAT PEOPLE WILL
NOT SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I DO
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IN THIS
COMMITTEE, IN THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF, WE HAVE INCREASED
PENALTIES FOR THOSE THAT VIOLATE
THE LAW. WE HAVE HELD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE. WE HAVE ALSO HAD
NOT ONLY RESTORATIVE BILLS THAT
HAVE COME THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
THAT WE HAVE SUPPORTED, AS WELL
AS PUNITIVE BILLS. WE HAVE BEEN
AS FAIR AS POSSIBLE. I WOULD ASK
FOR A MOTION AND ALSO ASK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, I APPRECIATE THE EFFORT
TO REALLY WANT TO PROTECT OUR
KIDS AT EVERY TURN. IT'S
OBVIOUSLY A PRIORITY FOR
HOPEFULLY ALL OF US AT THIS
COMMITTEE. AND SO I WOULD ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE FOR EVERYONE WHO
PUTS OUR KIDS FIRST. THANK YOU.
DO I HAVE A MOTION? SENATOR
SKINNER? AYE. I WILL MOVE THE
BILL. AND, EACH INDIVIDUAL WHO
SELLS OR EACH PERSON THAT SELLS
IS AN INDIVIDUAL. AND THIS BILL
WOULD HOLD THOSE PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE TO UPHOLD OUR LAW.
AND I THINK THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT WANT TO HELP MAKE THEIR,
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN WITH OUR
FLAVORED TOBACCO AND SOME OF
THE, OTHER PRODUCTS LAWS WE'VE
HAD THAT MANY OF OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE TAKEN AN ACTIVE
ROLE IN ENFORCING. AND I THINK
WE WANT SIMILARLY HERE IN THIS
ALLOWS FOR OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO DO SO. SO I AM HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT AND MOVE IT. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
TABLE BY SENATOR SKINNER. ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB 2021. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
HAVE I HAVE I SATO. SATO. NO.
BRADFORD SKINNER. SKINNER I
WIENER THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR NEXT BILL? FILE
NUMBER 11 AB 2527. YES THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
I'M PRESENTING AB 2527, WHICH
SUPPORTS THE PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH OF INCARCERATED PREGNANT
PEOPLE BY ENSURING THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO BASIC NECESSITIES AND
A SAFE ENVIRONMENT. AB 2527 DOES
THREE PRIMARY THINGS. IT
CODIFIES NUTRITION STANDARDS FOR
INCARCERATED PREGNANT PEOPLE. IT
ENSURES THEY ARE PROVIDED WITH
AT LEAST 120OZ OF CLEANED
BOTTLED WATER EACH DAY, WHICH
THE OPPOSITION MAY, AS
PREVIOUSLY ARGUE, IS TOO MUCH
WATER FOR A PREGNANT PERSON. BUT
FOR ANYONE HERE WHO'S BEEN
PREGNANT, YOU WILL KNOW THERE'S
NO SUCH THING. AND IT PROHIBITS
THE USE OF SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
DURING PREGNANCY AND POSTPARTUM.
A REPORT FROM THE ACLU DISCUSSED
THE HARMS THAT ARE HAPPENING TO
PREGNANT PEOPLE IN OUR CARCERAL
SYSTEM. IT'S UNACCEPTABLE. AND
THESE ARE THE BARE MINIMUMS TO
PROTECT THESE WOMEN AND THE
CHILDREN THAT THEY WILL HAVE
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
ARE ANGELICA SANCHEZ FROM THE
ESSIE JUSTICE GROUP AND DUKE
COONEY WITH ACLU ACTION. TWO
MINUTES, GOOD AFTERNOON, SENATOR
WAHAB AND, MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
ANGELICA SANCHEZ. I'M WITH THE
ESSIE JUSTICE GROUP. I'M HERE TO
LET YOU GUYS KNOW MY STORY. IN
2004, I WAS INCARCERATED. I WAS
INCARCERATED FOR, LIKE, OVER A
YEAR. THE MAJORITY OF MY
PREGNANCY. I WAS IN L.A. COUNTY,
THE ONLY WATER THAT I EVER, YOU
KNOW, DRANK WAS FROM THE FAUCET
IN MY CELL. SO IT WASN'T
BOTTLED. IT WASN'T, YOU COULDN'T
BUY A CANTEEN, IT TASTED DIRTY.
THERE WAS. NO, I DIDN'T GET TO
SEE THE DOCTOR. YOU KNOW, I HAD
AN I WAS ANEMIC, I NEEDED IRON,
MY, YOU KNOW, THE FOOD THERE
SUCKED. SO, THE ONLY WATER THAT,
YOU KNOW, THAT WAS THERE, YOU
KNOW, FOR US WAS JUST THE ONE
FROM THE FAUCET. SEE, I ALSO HAD
, LITTLE DOCTOR VISITS, ALTHOUGH
I DIDN'T GO TO SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT WHEN I WAS PREGNANT,
I DID GO, YOU KNOW, OTHER TIMES.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT? I DIDN'T GET
NO VISITS. YOU GET NO
COMMISSARY. YOU. YOU'RE ACTUALLY
JUST TALKING TO YOURSELF, YOU
KNOW, IN A ROOM, FOUR WALLS. YOU
ACTUALLY GO CRAZY UP IN THERE,
PRETTY MUCH, YOU CAN'T GET NO
VISITS. I CANNOT IMAGINE ANYBODY
BEING PREGNANT AND ACTUALLY
BEING IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT. I
MEAN, THAT WOULD HARM THE BABY.
THAT WOULD HARM YOURSELF. YOUR
MENTAL STATE, EVERYTHING, SO
WITH THAT BEING SAID, AB 2527
WILL HAVE, DETERRED THE
EXPERIENCE OF ME AND WHAT I WENT
THROUGH. AND THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
PREGNANT, PEOPLE THAT ARE
INCARCERATED, PEOPLE FACE, BEING
TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND,
RECEIVING BETTER, PRENATAL CARE
AND ADEQUATE NUTRITION. ALSO,
THIS BILL WILL ALSO, IF IT WERE
TO BE IN PLACE, IT WOULD, YOU
KNOW, MY BABY ALSO CAME OUT
WITH, A LOT OF, LIKE, SHE JUST
CAME OUT WITH ILLNESSES THAT SHE
STILL SUFFERS FROM IT TODAY. YOU
KNOW, HER IMMUNE SYSTEM IS
REALLY LOW. REALLY DOWN, SO, I
MEAN, THIS BILL WILL REALLY HELP
US, FOR, YOU KNOW, PREGNANT
PEOPLE TO GET A BETTER, PRENATAL
CARE IN THEIR WATER, LIKE, AN
ESSENTIAL TO US, YOU KNOW? AND
IT SUCKS, YOU KNOW, WE DON'T GET
ANYTHING, YOU KNOW, IT'S THAT
WATER IS NASTY IN LA, YOU KNOW?
SO, I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU GUYS TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. I URGE YOU
GUYS TO, VOTE TO SUPPORT AB
2527. PLEASE HELP US MAKE
PROGRESS TOWARDS, GUARANTEEING
THAT PREGNANT PEOPLE ARE TREATED
WITH DIGNITY AND, AND, YOU KNOW,
RECEIVE NECESSARY PRENATAL CARE.
THANK YOU. AND I'LL ALSO HAVE
THE ME TOO LINE UP, AGAIN, WE
LIKE TO GO THROUGH THAT QUICKLY,
BUT PLEASE GO AHEAD. Dð COONEY,
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION. AB 2527 WILL SUPPORT THE
HEALTH AND DIGNITY OF PREGNANT
PEOPLE INCARCERATED IN OUR STATE
BY ENSURING CLEAN WATER,
NUTRITIOUS MEALS, AND THE
FREEDOM FROM THE INHUMANE
PRACTICE OF SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. IN 2016, THE ACLU
OF NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLISHED A REPORT,
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH BEHIND BARS
IN CALIFORNIA, THAT ANALYZED
INFORMATION OBTAINED THROUGH
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUESTS FROM
A DIVERSE SAMPLE OF OVER FIVE
DIFFERENT COUNTY JAILS. THE
REPORT FOUND THAT THE JAILS WERE
PUTTING PEOPLE'S HEALTH AT RISK
BY DENYING, DELAYING AND
IGNORING CRUCIAL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE. FINDINGS FROM THE
2016 REPORT HELPED LAY THE
FOUNDATION FOR THE PASSAGE OF
CALIFORNIA'S REPRODUCTIVE
DIGNITY FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE
ACT IN 2020. THIS ACT EXPANDED
REPRODUCTIVE AND PREGNANCY
RELATED HEALTH PROTECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA JAILS AND STATE
PRISONS. ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
CONTINUES TO WORK ON
IMPLEMENTING CALIFORNIA'S
REPRODUCTIVE DIGNITY FOR
INCARCERATED PEOPLE ACT, AND
BELIEVES THAT AB 2527 IS A
CRUCIAL EXPANSION OF THAT LAW
NECESSARY TO PROTECT
INCARCERATED, PREGNANT, AND
POSTPARTUM PEOPLE. INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS FACE HARSH
CONDITIONS, INCLUDING EXTREME
LEVELS OF HIGH STRESS, EXPOSURE
TO VIOLENCE AND ABUSE, AND
SUBSTANDARD HEALTH CARE. THESE
CAN LEAVE DEVASTATING IMPACTS.
THESE CAN HAVE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS ON BOTH THE HEALTH OF
THE MOTHER AND THEIR PREGNANCIES
, IN PARTICULAR PREGNANCIES,
PREGNANT INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS AND COUNTY
DETENTION FACILITIES REMAIN
SUBJECTED TO THE EXTREME STRESS
OF SOLITARY CONFINEMENT, WHICH
CAN LEAD TO PROLONGED
PSYCHOLOGICAL DISTRESS THAT CAN
HAVE SEVERE HARM. THE ISOLATION
THAT HAPPENS FROM SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT CAN RESULT IN
PREGNANCY COMPLICATIONS AND
AFFECT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
FETUS. FURTHERMORE, THE USE OF
RESTRICTIVE HOUSING CAN CAUSE
DELAYS IN ADDRESSING PREGNANCY
COMPLICATIONS, HIGHLIGHTING A
SYSTEMIC CHALLENGE WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA CARCERAL SYSTEM. FOR
THESE REASONS, WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. CAN
WE GET LEAD OPPOSITION? GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CORY SALZILLO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION, IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL, WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO
INCARCERATED, PREGNANT PERSONS
HAVING ACCESS TO NUTRITION OR
WATER, AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
AUTHOR WAS REFERRING TO IN TERMS
OF THE OPPOSITION SAYING THAT
120OZ IS TOO MUCH. WE'VE NEVER
OPINED ON AN AMOUNT OR THE
PROPRIETY OF 110OZ VERSUS 130OZ.
IN FACT, THAT GOES TO OUR
ARGUMENT, WHICH IS IT SHOULDN'T
BE PUT INTO STATUTE. THESE SORTS
OF THINGS, AS THEY ARE
CURRENTLY, SHOULD BE ADDRESSED
IN THE REGULATIONS THAT GOVERN
GOVERN THE STATE AND LOCAL
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEMS. IT'S MORE
APPROPRIATE THAN DOING SO IN
STATUTE, BECAUSE THE REGULATIONS
ARE CONSTANTLY UPDATED BY
STAKEHOLDERS ON ALL SIDES AND
EXPERTS WHO ACTUALLY WORK WITH
AND IMPLEMENT THESE ISSUES AND
HAVE SOME EXPERTISE FURTHER, OUR
MAIN CONCERN WITH THE BILL IS
THE BLANKET RESTRICTION ON THE
USE OF SOLITARY CONFINEMENT OR
RESTRICTIVE HOUSING UNIT
ASSIGNMENTS FOR PREGNANT PERSONS
FOR THE ENTIRETY OF THEIR
PREGNANCY, PLUS 12 WEEKS
POSTPARTUM WITHOUT ANY SORT OF
RECOGNITION OF ANY PARTICULAR,
CIRCUMSTANCES IN ANY PARTICULAR
CASE, THERE ARE ANY NUMBER OF
SITUATIONS WHERE THESE TYPES OF
HOUSING ASSIGNMENTS MAY BE THE
MOST APPROPRIATE AND SAFE FOR
THAT PERSON, OTHER INMATES AND
STAFF. BUT THIS BILL CREATES AN
OUTRIGHT BAN ON THEIR USE
WITHOUT REGARD TO THE SPECIFICS
OF ANY POTENTIAL SCENARIO. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS, WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER LEAD OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ME TO STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION, WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE, SHERVIN
AZAMI, ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE ACTION AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. KERRY
ARZATE, I'M SYSTEM IMPACTED. AND
I ALSO SUPPORT FAMILIES,
IMPACTED BY SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE AND I SUPPORT THE BILL
AND HAVE SOME METOOS AS WELL.
EMPOWERING WOMEN IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION, FELONY MURDER,
ELIMINATION PROJECT AND INITIATE
JUSTICE ACTION SUPPORTING THE
BILL. THANK YOU. YOLANDA
NAVARETTE WITH INITIATE JUSTICE,
INITIATE JUSTICE ACTION. FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT AND
FAMILIES UNITED TO END LOOP AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
RACHELLE HILL, MEMBER LEAD WITH
AC JUSTICE AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL. ME TOO. KATRINA REESE WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
WIENER VÀ CAMPOS WITH S.C.
JUSTICE GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND STEPHANIE FLORES, MEMBER
LEADER WITH SC JUSTICE GROUP
FROM MERCED, CALIFORNIA. AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT. CHRIS LADY
WITH SC JUSTICE GROUP SACRAMENTO
IN STRONG SUPPORT. KATINA PERRY
FROM IT'S NOT OKAY, MOMS FOR
CHANGE AND AC JUSTICE GROUP, AND
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS CHERISE GRIFFIN. I'M A
MEMBER LED AC JUSTICE GROUP IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MY NAME IS
ROXANNA GONZALEZ. ON BEHALF OF
LA FAMILIA LOPEZ AND RUBÉN
AGUIRRE INITIATE JUSTICE ACTION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
GLENN BACKUS, ELLA BAKER, CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, MICHELLE GILES, AC
JUSTICE GROUP AND STRONG SUPPORT
LESLIE CALDWELL, HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, LIZZIE BRÜCKEN WITH
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, ANNALISA
ZAMORA WITH YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER AND STRONG
SUPPORT, ALICIA MONTEIRO WOULD
JUST ADVOCATE, INSTRUCT,
SUPPORT. EXCUSE ME. GOOD
MORNING. I'M RENEE ROGERS WITH
I'M AN OUTSIDE ORGANIZER WITH
INITIATED JUSTICE. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT LAURA LARIOS, OUTSIDE
ORGANIZER FOR INITIATE JUSTICE.
STRONGLY SUPPORT ERIC HENDERSON
ON BEHALF OF VERA CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS WILLING TO SPEAK,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR
SKINNER, I WILL MOVE THE BILL. I
APPRECIATE YOUR DOING THIS.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY, WE'VE HAD
TO DO STATUTES THAT WE SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO DO, LIKE STATUTES
AROUND A NOT SHACKLING OF,
PREGNANT PEOPLE WHILE THEY'RE IN
LABOR AND VARIOUS OTHER THAT
JUST FROM A MEDICAL PERSPECTIVE
MAKE NO SENSE. THIS IS,
APOLOGIES TO THE SHERIFFS, BUT I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THERE WOULD
BE OPPOSITION. AND I ALSO, I
THINK WHY WE HAVE TO PUT THIS IN
STATUTE AND WHY IT IS NOT OUR
PRACTICE IS, MYSTIFIES ME, BUT I
WILL MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, YES, I THINK I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT NOTHING IN THE BILL
STOPS THE SHERIFFS FROM
EXCEEDING THE 120OZ. SO WE'RE
JUST PUTTING A FLOOR IN. IF THEY
WANT TO REGULATE THAT, THERE IS
MORE. WE WELCOME THAT. BUT THIS
IS REALLY THE BARE MINIMUM TO
PROTECT PREGNANT WOMEN AND THEIR
SOON TO BE CHILDREN. WITH THAT,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER. CAN
WE GET A ROLL CALL, PLEASE? ITEM
NUMBER 11 AB 2527. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WE'LL HAVE I, II SEYARTO SATO
NOT VOTING. BRADFORD SKINNER.
SKINNER I WIENER BILLS ON CALL.
THANK YOU. COMMITTEE SERGEANTS,
CAN WE MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
CALLING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS?
STAFFERS, IF YOU GUYS CAN CALL
YOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA, CARILLO, GABRIEL
HANEY, PAPAN, AND FRIEDMAN,
PLEASE. ALL RIGHT. OH, YEAH.
CARILLO IS PULLED. SORRY. GOING
TO GO.
THE END OF THAT. YEAH. NO. MY
PARENTS WERE LIKE ONCE. WE LIKE.
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR SENIORS. FOR
SURE. WHY ARE YOU. WHY ARE YOU.
WHY ARE YOU STARTING WITH THIS?
LIKE WE CAN? NEVER HAVE. I THINK
YOU'RE STARTING FROM A PLACE OF.
SO. YEAH YEAH. YEAH PRETTY SURE
THAT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS. IT'S
LIKE. LIKE POTION. POTION? BE
DOING ANYTHING. BUT HERE'S, LIKE
.
THAT'S. THAT'S THE POLICY. YEAH.
YEAH, YEAH, IT'S A GREAT. YEAH.
I NEED TO KEEP THE ONE FOR ONE
MORE. WE'RE DOING PRETTY GOOD,
THOUGH. YEAH, WE'RE WE'RE FINE.
AND IF COLORADO. I'M JUST SAYING
I GOT, LIKE, YOU DISH TO BE AT
IF YOU WANT. I MEAN JUDICIAL. WE
ONLY GOT FIVE. WE'LL SEND IT TO
DISH RIGHT. YEAH. AFTERNOON. NO,
IT STARTED AT 930. THIS MORNING.
OKAY. WIENER IS COMING BACK.
YEAH. BECAUSE THEY DON'T DO
HEARINGS EARLY ENOUGH.
LET'S LIFT THE CALL. ITEM NUMBER
TWO. AB 628. MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 1. BRADFORD. BRADFORD I.
THAT'S STILL ON CALL. THAT BILL
IS STILL ON CALL. AB THREE. I
MEAN, SORRY. ITEM THREE, AB
1252. WICKS MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 1 BRADFORD BRADFORD I THAT
BILLS OUT. ITEM EIGHT AB 1892.
FLORA MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I THAT BILLS
OUT. ITEM TEN A B 2021
BAUER-KAHAN MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS 2 TO 1. BRADFORD BRADFORD. I
CALL THAT BILL IS ON CALL. ITEM
11 2527 BAUER-KAHAN MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I THAT GOES
ON. CALL. ITEM 1520 308 DAVIES.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. BRADFORD BRADFORD I
WIENER. YOU WERE HERE FOR THAT?
I DON'T THINK HE WAS. I DON'T
THINK HE WAS HERE. DO YOU HAVE
AN I WIENER ON THAT ONE OR WAS
HE GONE ON DAVIES ABOUT NUMBER
ONE, NO. OKAY. HE WAS HE WAS OUT
THERE. OKAY. I JUST MISSED IT.
OKAY. 4 TO 1. THAT'S OUR CALL. 4
TO 1. THAT BILLS ON CALL 4 TO 0.
OKAY PAUL WAS ON HIS WAY HERE.
NOW IS THAT I THINK I'VE GOT YOU
FOR EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW. THAT
WAS ON CALL. IT WAS YOU GOT HIM
FOR EVERYTHING THAT WAS ON CALL.
YES. YES FEISTY LITTLE MOVE
TODAY. BUT YOU GOT TO SAY YES, I
KNOW, I'LL LET YOU KNOW WHEN
JUDICI WANTS YOU. BECAUSE I'M
TEXTING WITH HER BECAUSE YOU
HAVE AN ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY. I'M
ALWAYS WRONG, I KNOW. WELL,
EVERYBODY WANTS YOU, BUT. OKAY.
NO.
IT'S MY FAVORITE THING TO DO IS
TO WAIT. JUST.
ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAYNIE WILL BE PRESENTING HIS
BILL. FILE NUMBER 18, AB 2629
JUMPED ON YOU BEFORE YOU GOT
HIM. RIGHT TIMING, THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AB 2629 WILL CLOSE
A LOOPHOLE IN EXISTING LAW THAT
ALLOWS PEOPLE WHO ARE DEEMED
MENTALLY INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL TO PURCHASE AND BUY GUNS.
THIS IS ALREADY THE LAW WHEN IT
COMES TO PEOPLE WHO ARE DEEMED
MENTALLY INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL FOR FELONY TRIALS. YET IF
SOMEBODY IS FOUND TO BE SO IN A
MISDEMEANOR TRIAL THAT IS NOT
PASSED ON TO OUR DATABASE IN A
WAY THAT ENSURES THAT THEY
SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO PURCHASE A
FIREARM, THIS IS ALREADY THE
CASE IN FEDERAL LAW AND IN
FEDERAL COURTS. IF YOU ARE
DEEMED MENTALLY INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL, YOU SHOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE A GUN THAT IS
DANGEROUS TO YOU. IT'S DANGEROUS
TO THE COMMUNITY AND THIS IS A
SIMPLE COMMON SENSE LAW THAT
WILL CLOSE A LOOPHOLE AND
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY. WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS
MYRA MORALES, ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
FROM THE BUREAU OF FIREARMS, AND
CANDACE CHUNG, A DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THANK
YOU. YOU'LL HAVE TWO MINUTES.
OKAY. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATORS, AGAIN. WELL, WE'D
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HANEY FOR AUTHORING THIS BILL.
AGAIN. THIS BILL JUST SIMPLY
CLOSES WHAT APPEARS TO BE AN
UNINTENDED LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW.
EXISTING STATE LAW ALREADY BANS
INDIVIDUALS, FOUND INCOMPETENT,
STAND TRIAL IN VIRTUALLY EVERY
SITUATION. FELONY CASES IF IT'S
A MISDEMEANOR FROM FEDERAL COURT
OR A MISDEMEANOR FROM ANOTHER
STATE. IT'S ALSO PROHIBITED
UNDER FEDERAL LAW. SO IT'S
INEXPLICABLE, INEXPLICABLY, THAT
THAT A FINDING OF INCOMPETENCE
IN A MISDEMEANOR CASE FROM THIS
STATE DOESN'T TRIGGER THE SAME
SORT OF FIREARM PROHIBITION. AND
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A STATE
PROHIBITOR, DOJ NEVER RECEIVES
THIS INFORMATION FROM THE
COURTS, WHICH WOULD ALLOW US TO
BLOCK INDIVIDUALS FROM PASSING
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND TO ACQUIRE
GUNS. NOR DO WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO REMOVE FIREARMS
FROM THESE INDIVIDUALS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS HAS RESULTED
IN DANGEROUS SITUATIONS WHERE
DEFENDANTS HAVE REMAINED IN
POSSESSION OF FIREARMS AFTER
THEY WERE FOUND MENTALLY
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL,
INCLUDING FOR OFFENSES THAT
INVOLVE VIOLENCE OR MISUSE OF A
WEAPON. I DO WANT TO TAKE A
SECOND TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS, THE GOAL
OF THIS BILL IS TO ENSURE THAT
SOMEONE WHO IS FOUND INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL AND ATTEMPTS TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM, THAT THEY'RE
PROHIBITED FROM DOING, SO. IT'S
NOT OUR GOAL TO EXPOSE PEOPLE TO
ADDITIONAL PROSECUTIONS OR TO
LEAD TO ADDITIONAL ARRESTS,
WE'VE HAD SOME PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE ACLU AND,
YOU KNOW, AND DISCUSSIONS ON HOW
MAYBE BEST TO CLARIFY THE INTENT
OF THAT BILL OF THIS BILL, BUT,
YOU KNOW, WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE SUFFERING
FROM MENTAL ILLNESS ARE NOT
VIOLENT, AND IT'S OUR HOPE THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PROSECUTORS
WOULD CONSIDER MENTAL CAPACITY
AND ONLY SPARINGLY PROSECUTE
THESE IF THERE IS A VIOLATION.
BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
MENTAL INCOMPETENCY FINDINGS
ONLY OCCUR IN CASES INVOLVING
FAIRLY SEVERE IMPAIRMENTS THAT
WOULD TYPICALLY INDICATE THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL CANNOT BE
EXPECTED TO SAFELY POSSESS A
FIREARM OR COMPLY WITH STATE GUN
LAWS, AND RESPONSIBILITIES. AND
UNLIKE IN FELONY CASES WHERE A
DEFENDANT IS HELD, ENTREATED,
THE MAJORITY OF THESE
MISDEMEANOR CASES, THE
INDIVIDUALS JUST RELEASED
WITHOUT TREATMENT OR
SUPERVISION, BUT RETAINING THEIR
ACCESS TO FIREARMS. SO THIS BILL
SHORES UP THE SAFETY NET IN
CALIFORNIA, AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
NEXT SPEAKER, I HAVE THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR HERE, AND
SHE'S AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IF YOU NEED. OKAY.
PERFECT. NO OTHER LEAD WITNESSES
. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO LEAD OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ME, TWO'S MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS,
DAN FELIZARDO, ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION, WE ARE
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED, BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS SEEING NONE. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. CAN I GET A
MOTION? SO MOVED. THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER. ITEM
18 AB 2629. HAYNIE. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB Ã
I SEYARTO BRADFORD SKINNER. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WIENER AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL'S ON CALL. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA, PAPIN AND
FRIEDMAN. EXCUSE. LITERALLY JUST
GABRIEL AND GABRIEL. WHERE'D HE
GO? IS HE IN THE HALLWAY? NO.
ALL RIGHT. YEAH. HE DIDN'T GO
BACK. HE GOT ALL THE WAY BACK TO
JUDICI. HE'S OKAY. I THINK.
THAT'S WHY HE'S TAKING TIME. SO
MAYBE NOT.
LET'S LIFT THE CALLS FOR SENATOR
WIENER. ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB 628.
WILSON. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 1. WIENER WIENER. AYE
BELLSOUTH. THAT BILLS OUT. ITEM
TEN A B 2021 BAUER-KAHAN. MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1. WIENER
WIENER. AYE BILLS OUT FOR ONE
THAT BILLS OUT 4 TO 1. MAYBE.
ITEM 11 A B 2527 BAUER-KAHAN
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. WIENER WIENER. AYE THAT
BILLS OUT 4 TO 0. ITEM 15 AB
2308 DAVIES. MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 0. WIENER WIENER. AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT 5 TO 0. VOTE
NUMBER. WE ALREADY GOT THAT. I
THINK I'M GOOD. SIX. YEAH, WE
ALREADY GOT RAMOS. WE ALREADY
GOT THAT'S IT.
WE. I THINK WE ADDED HIM BEFORE.
YEAH WE DID, WE ADDED HE CAME.
HE ADDED ON WHEN HE WAS IN BED
FOR SNUCK OUT. LET'S SEE. 4 TO
1. YEAH. BINGO. SICK. EARLY ON
THE MEMBERS. HE'S HERE. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED. I MEAN, WHAT HAPPENED?
A CALL. DO WE HAVE ALL THE
SENATORS ON ALL THE BILLS? SO
FAR? YES. SO WHAT? BRAD FROM
BRADFORD, THERE WAS JUST THE
LAST ONE. BRADFORD EXCEPT FOR
THAT ONE. THE BRADFORD SALADO
ARE OFF ON THIS ON THE ONE THAT
HANEY JUST DID I THINK OTHER
THAN THAT ONE. OKAY. SOUNDS NICE
. THAT'S WHAT I WOULD DO.
HERE. OTHER THAN THAT, WE'RE
COVERED. OKAY. YEAH ALL RIGHT. I
TOLD ALLISON MERRILEES TO TEXT
CALL IF HE'S IN THIS BUILDING.
STILL.
I THINK LET'S LIFT THE CALL FOR
SENATOR SALADO. HANG ON. LET ME
LOOK. ITEM NUMBER 18, FILE ITEM
NUMBER 18. PRETTY SURE I'M UP. I
WAS READING TWO WEEKS. AB 2629.
HANEY. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. SEYARTO NIGHT. HI, SATO.
I SAID BILLS ON CALL. HE JUST
LAUGHED. MAYBE LIKE FIVE MINUTES
AGO.
IT MUST BE ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE FILE ITEM 20 5AB
3088 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN, PLEASE PRESENT. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
3088 SEEKS TO ARTICULATE THE
STANDARD BY WHICH PROCEDURAL
BARRIERS CAN BE OVERCOME BY
INNOCENT INDIVIDUALS ATTEMPTING
TO SECURE THEIR RELEASE FROM
PRISON THROUGH HABEAS CORPUS
PETITIONS. THIS IS NOT THIS IS
NOT ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST
GOING INTO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THIS IS ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
ARE CURRENTLY INCARCERATED, AND
NEW EVIDENCE COMES UP THAT CAN
PROVE THEIR INNOCENCE. AND IT'S
ABOUT THE STANDARD BY WHICH WE
ALLOW A JUDGE TO HEAR THAT
EVIDENCE AND HAVE A RETRIAL IN
THE ABSENCE OF A EXISTING IN THE
ABSENCE OF A OF A STATUTE UNDER
EXISTING CASE LAW, THE
PROCEDURAL BARRIERS OF
TIMELINESS AND SUCCESS OF
PETITION CONSIDERATIONS OFTEN
BAR INCARCERATED PEOPLE FROM
HAVING THEIR CLAIMS HEARD BY A
COURT, EVEN WHEN NEW EVIDENCE OF
INNOCENCE IS AVAILABLE BECAUSE
OF NEW TECHNOLOGY WITNESS
CHANGING THEIR MINDS, THAT SORT
OF THING. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
FOR HABEAS PETITIONS IMPLICATING
A WRONGFUL CONVICTION TO BE
EVALUATED ON THEIR MERITS,
RATHER THAN IMMEDIATELY BEING
DISMISSED BASED ON PROCEDURAL
GROUNDS. CAN YOU IMAGINE HOW
FRUSTRATING THAT WOULD BE? IF
YOU'RE SOMEONE IN PRISON WHO
WERE TOLD, HEY, WE DO THINK
YOU'RE INNOCENT, BUT BECAUSE TOO
MUCH TIME HAS PASSED, WE CAN'T
GIVE YOU A NEW TRIAL.
IMPORTANTLY, THE COURT WOULD
STILL HAVE DISCRETION WHETHER
THERE SHOULD BE A HEARING BASED
ON THE MERITS OF THE CASE. AB
3088 SIMPLY ARTICULATES A
STANDARD BY WHICH THE COURT CAN
OVERCOME TIMELINESS AND
SUCCESSIVENESS. THIS WILL BRING
INNOCENCE CLAIMS MORE IN LINE
WITH OTHER STATES AND WITH
FEDERAL COURT STANDARDS. I'M
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING THE
CONCERN RAISED BY OPPOSITION
REGARDING THE ONE JUROR NOT
CONVICTING THE PETITIONER IN
LIGHT OF NEW EVIDENCE, THUS
CONTINUING TO WORK IN GOOD FAITH
SHOULD THIS BILL PASS OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY, TESTIFYING AND
SUPPORT THIS MORNING IS JASMINE
HARRIS, DIRECTOR OF POLICY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA INNOCENCE
COALITION. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, CHAIR AND
STAFF AS A ASSEMBLY FIRM, AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FRIEDMAN SAID,
MY NAME IS JASMINE HARRIS AND
I'M THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA INNOCENCE COALITION.
WE'RE PROUD SPONSORS OF AB 3088
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN DID AN
EXCELLENT JOB DESCRIBING THE
NEED FOR THE BILL AND THE
SOLUTION. AB 3088 OFFERS. I WILL
JUST ADD THAT THE RESULT OF THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS INCARCERATED.
INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE BARRED FROM
HABEAS PETITION CONSIDERATION
DUE TO PROCEDURAL BARRIERS THAT
KEEP THEM IN PRISON, NOT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE EVIDENCE OF
INNOCENCE, BUT BECAUSE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE RELY ON CASE LAW,
WHICH SETS AN INCREDIBLY HIGH
STANDARD. CURRENTLY, IF THE
PETITIONER IS FILING A
SUCCESSIVE OR UNTIMELY PETITION
AND THEY CANNOT PROVE THAT THE
EVIDENCE IN THEIR PETITION
COMPLETELY UNDERMINES THE
PROSECUTION'S CASE AND POINTS
UNERRINGLY TO INNOCENCE, WHICH
IS ALMOST AN IMPOSSIBLE
STANDARD, THEIR CLAIM WILL BE
DISMISSED BEFORE THE COURT CAN
LOOK AT THE MERITS IN THE
PETITION. THIS STANDARD IS NOT
ONLY THE HIGHEST STANDARD IN THE
COUNTRY, BUT IS ALSO THE HIGHEST
. IT IS ALSO HIGHER THAN THE
STANDARD REQUIRED TO REVERSE A
CONVICTION HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SINCE 2016, WE ARE SIMPLY ASKING
TO BRING THE PROCEDURAL BAR
STANDARD IN LINE WITH THE
STANDARD USED TO REVERSE A
CONVICTION. MANY OF YOU ON THIS
COMMITTEE ARE CHAMPIONS OF
INNOCENCE, AND WE APPRECIATE
THIS. AND I KNOW YOU ALREADY
KNOW THIS, BUT I WOULD BE REMISS
NOT TO SAY EVERY MOMENT SPENT
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED IS A GRAVE
INJUSTICE. IN MY EXPERIENCE,
WORKING WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
INNOCENT AND INCARCERATED EVERY
DAY THAT PASSES WHILE THEY'RE
WRONGFULLY INCARCERATED IS
EXCRUCIATING. EACH DAY IS A DAY
WITHOUT THEIR FAMILIES. ANOTHER
BIRTHDAY CELEBRATED WITHOUT
THEM, ANOTHER FUNERAL MISSED.
EVERY DAY IS ANOTHER DAY.
THEY'RE SUFFERING A CRUEL
PUNISHMENT NOT MEANT FOR THEM.
THIS BILL HELPS BRING JUSTICE TO
THE WRONGFULLY INCARCERATED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER LEAD WITNESSES? SEEING
NONE, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
LEAD OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
GARRETT HAMILTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
. THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A
MANDATE FOR COURTS TO DISREGARD
LONG STANDING RULES THAT REQUIRE
HABEAS CORPUS. PETITIONERS TO
FILE NEW CLAIMS IN A TIMELY
MANNER AND PROHIBIT REPETITIVE
ATTEMPTS TO RAISE PREVIOUSLY
REJECTED CLAIMS. THESE
PROCEDURAL RULES ALREADY PERMIT
A COURT TO HEAR A PETITION THAT
IS UNDULY DELAYED, OR
SUCCESSIVE. IF THE COURT FINDS
THAT THE CLAIMS RAISED WOULD
SHOW A FUNDAMENTAL MISCARRIAGE
OF JUSTICE. AB 3088, HOWEVER,
WOULD MANDATE THE COURT HEAR AND
OTHERWISE BARRED PETITION BASED
ON A FINDING THAT A SINGLE JUROR
WOULD FOR ANY REASON, NOT HAVE
CONVICTED THE DEFENDANT. IT
WOULD ALSO PERMIT A COURT TO
IGNORE ABUSIVE USE OF WRIT
PETITIONS. SUCH ABUSES INCLUDE
REPEATED PETITIONS RAISING THE
SAME CLAIMS OR REPETITIVE
PETITIONS, EACH RAISING ONLY
PART OF A CLAIM, EVEN THOUGH THE
ENTIRETY OF THE INFORMATION WAS
KNOWN AT THE TIME OF FILING THE
ORIGINAL WRIT. ABUSES ALSO
INCLUDE USING A WRIT TO RAISE
ISSUES THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DECIDED ON THEIR MERITS. UNDER
THIS BILL, AB 3088, A PETITIONER
COULD FILE MULTIPLE PETITIONS
RAISING THE SAME CLAIM, EVEN IF
A COURT HAS ALREADY DETERMINED
THE CLAIM IS WITHOUT MERIT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES
SEEING NONE. ME TWOS BOTH IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION, PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER OR NOT
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. GLENN
BACKUS, ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, SHIRVAN NIZAMI ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE ACTION AND THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THE SPEED. KERRY
ARZATE WITH PRISON FROM THE
INSIDE OUT COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
ALSO WITH INITIATE JUSTICE,
INITIATE JUSTICE ACTION AND I
HAVE A COUPLE OF METOOS
EMPOWERING WOMEN IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION AS WELL AS FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. YOLANDA NAVARETTE
REPRESENTING INITIATE JUSTICE,
INITIATE JUSTICE ACTION. FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT
FAMILIES UNITED TO END LOOP AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LESLIE CALDWELL, HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. I'M
SORRY I CAN'T TALK FAST. ERIC
HENDERSON ON BEHALF OF SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
Dð CðC ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE, WOULD
YOU GUYS LIKE TO SPEAK SEEING
NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
JUST THE COURT STILL HAS
DISCRETION ON WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WANT TO OPEN A CASE. THIS
IS JUST SAYING THAT PROCEDURAL
SORT OF A SOMEWHAT ARBITRARY
PROCEDURAL GROUND SHOULD NOT
STOP SOMEONE IF THERE'S REAL
EVIDENCE THAT THEY ARE INNOCENT
FROM A COURT DECIDING WHETHER
THEY WANT TO HEAR THE CASE.
THANK YOU. AND I WANT TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, DO
YOU ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS? YES, YES. ALL RIGHT.
PERFECT DO WE HAVE A MOTION? DO
WE HAVE A MOTION, GUYS? THANK
YOU. SENATOR WIENER MOVES THE
BILL, CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL,
PLEASE? ITEM 25, AB 38, AB 3088.
FRIEDMAN. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB
I SATO. SATO. NO. BRADFORD.
SKINNER. WIENER. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL IS ON CALL. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CALL
REPRESENTING FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB 459. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR. BEFORE FIVE NINE WOULD
MAKE IMPLEMENTATION FIXES TO THE
RACIAL AND IDENTITY PROFILING
ACT THAT WOULD IMPROVE THE FINAL
DATA SETS OVERALL QUALITY AND
FACILITATE BETTER PUBLIC ACCESS
TO THE INFORMATION. IN 2015, THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB 953, WHICH
ESTABLISHED RIPA TO ELIMINATE
RACIAL AND IDENTITY IDENTITY
PROFILING BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
UNDER EXISTING LAW REPORTING
AGENCIES SUCH AS LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE CHP ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT DATA ON
POLICE STOPS TO THE DOJ
ANNUALLY. HOWEVER, FOLLOWING THE
COMPLETION OF THE 2023 RIPA DATA
REPORTING PERIOD, 14% OF
REPORTING AGENCIES SUBMITTED
INCOMPLETE SUBMISSIONS OR DATA
WITH ERRORS THAT COULD NOT THAT
COULD NOT BE REMEDIED BEFORE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE RIPA BOARD
FOR THEIR ANALYSIS AND ANNUAL
REPORT. ADDITIONALLY, WHILE THE
STATUTE REQUIRES ALL RIPA DATA
TO BE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AND
SPECIFIED, SPECIFIES THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION OF THE INDIVIDUALS
STOPPED OR THE OFFICERS INVOLVED
ARE NOT REPORTED, THE PII IS
STILL BEING INCLUDED IN THE OPEN
TEXT DATA FIELDS. THIS IS
DESPITE TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE DOJ AND HAS
LED TO MUCH OF THIS INFORMATION
BEING UNAVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
DUE TO PRIVACY CONCERNS. AB 459
ADDRESSES ADDRESSES THESE ISSUES
BY FIRST UPDATING THE ANNUAL
SUBMISSION DEADLINE FROM APRIL
1ST TO MARCH 1ST, TO ALLOW THE
DOJ MORE TIME TO RESOLVE ERRORS.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL
INCENTIVIZES REPORTING AGENCIES
TO MEET EXISTING DEADLINES WITH
MINIMAL ERRORS OR, AT A MINIMUM,
WORK WITH THE DOJ BY INCREASING
THE REPORTING FREQUENCY TO TWICE
ANNUALLY FOR AGENCIES THAT FAIL
TO COMPLY. LASTLY THE BILL WOULD
ADDRESS CONCERNS RELATED TO THE
MISREPORTING OF PII IN OPEN TEXT
AND NARRATIVE FIELDS BY
ESTABLISHING A PROCESS FOR
RESEARCHERS TO APPLY FOR FULL
ACCESS TO INFORMATION UNDER A
CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENT
MODELED AFTER EXISTING
DISCLOSURE PROCESSES FOR
INFORMATION RELATED TO FIREARMS
AND CRIMINAL HISTORY. OTHER
REQUESTS ARE SEEKING ACCESS TO
THE OPEN TEXT AND NARRATIVE
FIELDS. MUST FILE A PRA REQUEST.
THE RESPECTIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY REPORTING LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPORTING AGENCY, WHICH WOULD
THEN BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
REDACTING ANY PII. PII INCLUDED
IN THOSE FIELDS. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS CANDICE
CHUNG, LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, AND
DAMON BROWN. SPECIAL ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL, WHO IS
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, I'M CANDICE CHUNG ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR, ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROB BONTA. WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
DETAILED ANALYSIS. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA FOR HIS AUTHORSHIP
OF THIS BILL. THE DOJ REALIZED
THAT WE NEEDED THIS BILL, DURING
OUR IMPLEMENTATION OF RIPA,
WHILE WE WOULD HAVE LIKED TO
HAVE INTRODUCED THIS BILL
EARLIER, WE HAD TO WAIT ON THE
2023 DATA TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE STATUTE
WERE EVIDENCE BASED AND TAILORED
TO OUR FINDINGS. SO THIS BILL
BEFORE YOU IS INFORMED BY TWO
YEARS OF FULL STATEWIDE DATA
REPORTING, WITH THE LAST
REPORTING PERIOD ENDING IN APRIL
1ST. BUT TO ESTABLISH A SENSE OF
SCALE, WE HAVE OVER 500 LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES STATEWIDE
THAT BEGAN REPORTING RIPA DATA
TO DOJ TWO YEARS AGO, WITH MORE
THAN 4.7 MILLION STOPS COLLECTED
JUST FOR 2023 ALONE. THESE
IMPLEMENTATION FIXES ARE
NECESSARY TO ALLOW DOJ THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
REPORTING AGENCIES TO RECTIFY
ERRORS AND TO ENSURE THAT THE
SUBSET OF OPEN TEXT FIELDS IN
THE RIPA DATASET ARE TRULY,
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE, AS THE LAW
REQUIRES, AND TO MAKE THE RIPA
DATA AVAILABLE FOR EDUCATIONAL
RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY PURPOSES,
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. OTHERWISE, WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SO THE LETTER AND INTENT
OF THE RIPA DATA COLLECTION AND
ACCESS TO DATA IS FULLY
REALIZED, IF YOU HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS I HAVE WITH
ME, OUR SPECIAL ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL, DAMON BROWN,
WHO ADVISES ON CIVIL RIGHTS
MATTERS. THANK YOU. WE'LL MOVE
ON TO LEAD OPPOSITION. TWO
MINUTES, TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. CORY
SALZILLO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION, RESPECTFULLY, IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL, WE HAVE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO MEET WITH
THE SPONSORS. IN FACT, WE'RE
MEETING WITH THEM LATER TODAY.
BUT A COUPLE OF DISCRETE ISSUES.
THE BILL FAILS TO DEFINE THE
TERMS REPORTING ISSUES AND
UNRESOLVED ERRORS, MEANING THE
CRITERIA THAT WOULD BE USED BY
THE AG TO DETERMINE THAT AN
AGENCY MUST INCREASE THE
FREQUENCY OF ITS REPORTING IS
UNCLEAR. IT'S ALSO POSSIBLE THAT
WHATEVER ISSUES TRIGGER THE AG
TO DECIDE THAT MORE FREQUENT
REPORTING IS NEEDED TO REMEDY
THOSE REPORTING ISSUES OR
UNRESOLVED ERRORS WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY BE RESOLVED BY MORE
FREQUENT REPORTING. SO THE WE'RE
NOT SORT OF CLEAR ON IT JUST
SORT OF FEELS LIKE A PENALTY
BOX, FOR THOSE WHO HAVE ISSUES
WITH THEIR REPORTING,
ADDITIONALLY, THIS REMOVES
RESPONSIBILITY TO DISCLOSE
INFORMATION ABOUT PUBLICLY THE
INFORMATION THAT'S MADE PUBLIC
BY STATUTE FROM THE AG'S OFFICE
AND PLACES IT SOLELY WITH THE
REPORTING AGENCY. AND THIS
PROVISION, ALONG WITH THE BILL'S
OTHER REQUIREMENTS, WILL RESULT
IN INCREASED COST FOR AND DEMAND
MORE RESOURCES FROM LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. I
UNDERSTAND DOJ DOESN'T WANT TO
REPORT THESE THINGS, SO THEY'RE
SHIFTING THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
LOCAL AGENCIES IN THIS BILL. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS, WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
LEAD OPPOSITION SEEING NONE,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ME,
TWO'S SEEING NONE. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
SEEING NO COMMENTS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. CAN I GET A
MOTION, PLEASE? COULD I GET A
MOTION, PLEASE? THANK YOU.
SENATOR WIENER MOVES THE BILL.
ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 459. CALL
FOR MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. WAHAB Ã.
AYE. SEYARTO BRAD SATO. NO.
BRADFORD SKINNER. WIENER WIENER.
AYE THAT BILL IS ON CALL, I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPAN, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT. THANK YOU. AB
2692, FILE ITEM NUMBER 19 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPAN. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'D LIKE TO START BY
SAYING I'LL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. AND I'M GRATEFUL
TO YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF, FOR WORKING SO
CLOSELY WITH MY OFFICE TO GET
THIS BILL IN A BETTER FORM, AB
2692 IS ABOUT ENSURING THE
DEFENDANTS AND DIVERSION GET ALL
THE MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT THEY
NEED. BY WAY OF BACKGROUND,
COURTS ARE AUTHORIZED TO FIND
CERTAIN INCOMPETENT DEFENDANTS
ELIGIBLE, ELIGIBLE FOR
DIVERSION. THESE PARTICIPANTS
ARE MOST OFTEN INDIVIDUALS
DIAGNOSED WITH SCHIZOPHRENIA,
SCHIZOAFFECTIVE DISORDER, OR
BIPOLAR DISORDER WHO HAVE BEEN
FOUND INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
FOR FELONY CHARGES. THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF THE PROGRAM IS TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
FOR THE DEFENDANT, NOT PREPARE
THEM TO BE RETURNED TO
COMPETENCY, AND TO STAND TRIAL
AND BE PROSECUTED. CURRENT
STATUTE LIMITS THE AVAILABILITY,
TREATMENT PERIOD TO TWO YEARS,
BUT DOES NOT CLEARLY ADDRESS
WHEN THE TWO YEAR TREATMENT TIME
BEGINS, WHICH HAS LED TO THE
CLOCK STARTING AT THE
DETERMINATION OF INCOMPETENCE
AND NOT THE COMMENCEMENT OF
TREATMENT, BECAUSE IT CAN TAKE A
FEW MONTHS FOR A DEFENDANT TO
ENTER, TO ENTER INTO DIVERSION.
THIS CRITICAL TREATMENT THAT'S
REALLY OWED TO THE DEFENDANT IS
OFTEN MUCH SHORTER THAN INTENDED
BY LAW. AB 2692 NHÀ IS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED, WOULD ALLOW
COURTS TO ADD UP TO FOUR MONTHS
TO THE DIVERSION PERIOD TO
ENSURE THAT PROMISING TREATMENT
ISN'T CUT SHORT. THIS WILL. THIS
WILL GUARANTEE THAT DIVERTED
DEFENDANTS RECEIVE THE FULL
BENEFIT OF THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT TO ENSURE THEIR LONG
TERM STABILITY AND AT THE SAME
TIME IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY. HERE
TO TESTIFY WITH ME TODAY IS MISS
KRISTIN ALLISON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NØ. I THINK KHÓ
HOPPER IS HERE. THAT'S WHO'S
HERE TO TESTIFY. YOU HAVE 1 OR 2
WITNESSES. ONE. WE GOT ONE. ALL
RIGHT. SORRY. MY NOTES WERE NOT
UPDATED. NO WORRIES. TWO MINUTES
PLEASE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M
HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT MEASURE AB
2692. I'M SPEAKING NOT ONLY FOR
MYSELF, BUT ON BEHALF OF PHASE
ME OF SACRAMENTO, WHICH IS
FAMILY ADVOCATES OF INDIVIDUALS
FOR SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS AND
MANY OTHER MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCACY GROUPS. I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE A LIST TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ME, AB 26 HAS PERSONAL 2692
HAS PERSONAL AND URGENT
RELEVANCE. I SPEAK FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A FAMILY
SUPPORTER FOR OUR DAUGHTER WHO
HAS BEEN INVOLVED WITH THE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
PROGRAMS, SHE IS TOO ILL FROM
UNMANAGED PSYCHOSIS SYMPTOMS
STEMMING FROM SCHIZOAFFECTIVE
DISORDER CO-OCCURRING WITH
EPILEPSY AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TO SPEAK FOR HERSELF.
SHE IS 35 YEARS OLD AND HAS
TRIED DILIGENTLY FOR 15 YEARS TO
GAIN AND SUSTAIN RECOVERY,
REMISSION AND REJUVENATION. MY
DAUGHTER'S BRAIN IS INTERRUPTED
BY PARANOIA, DELUSIONS,
DEPRESSION, CYCLING WITH MANIA,
AND LOOPING THOUGHTS WITH NO
ABILITY TO CONCENTRATE OR
BELIEVE. INFORMATION FROM
COMPETENCY TRAINING. SHE IS A
PERFECT CANDIDATE FOR DIVERSION,
WHERE THE GOAL IS TREATMENT AND
STABILITY, NOT RESTORATION AND
COMPETENCY. MY DAUGHTER DESERVES
INTENSIVE AND EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT TO RETURN HER BRAIN TO
ITS ABILITY TO THINK, TO FOCUS,
TO PROCESS INFORMATION, AND TO
REGAIN ABILITY TO MAKE HEALTHY
CHOICES. THIS IS WHY I BELIEVE
THE FOCUS FOR INMATES WHO ARE
DEEMED INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL, ISD NEED TO BE ENGAGED
AND EFFECTIVE, SUSTAINED
TREATMENT WITH THE ABILITY OF
THE COURT TO CONTINUE TREATMENT
FOR UP TO FOUR MONTHS IN ORDER
FOR THE CLIENTS LIKE MY
DAUGHTER, TO PROGRESS, GAINING
AND RETAINING REMISSION OF BRAIN
ILLNESSES THAT INCLUDE PSYCHOSIS
SYMPTOMS IS NOT ALWAYS EASY FOR
PEOPLE WITH THESE TREATABLE
CONDITIONS. THE CORRECT PLACE TO
GET WELL IS NOT IN A CELL.
DIVERSION AND COMMUNITIES CAN
WORK. WHEN PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED
TO BE TWO WAY RESPONSIVE SYSTEMS
TO SYMPTOMS THAT RESPOND WELL TO
MEDICATIONS AND NON-MEDICATION
SUPPORTS, THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THESE VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVE THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
TREATMENT. AS AB 2692 ALLOWS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, I
APPRECIATE IT, SEEING NO OTHER
LEAD WITNESSES, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO LEAD OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. CHAIR. MEMBER Dð.
COONEY, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION, WE APPRECIATE
THE CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE, BUT WE
REMAIN IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO THE BILLS WRITTEN AB 2692. WE
FEEL THIS BILL CREATES
INEQUITIES AND RAISES DUE
PROCESS AND EQUAL PROTECTION
CONCERNS UNDER AB 2692,
INDIVIDUALS MAY SERVE
DRASTICALLY DIFFERENT TERMS OF
DIVERSION BASED SOLELY ON THE
COUNTY'S AVAILABLE RESOURCES,
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
THOSE WHO LIVE UNDER
UNDER-RESOURCED COMMUNITIES. BY
LIMITING STATUTORY GUARDRAILS,
AB 2692 PERPETUATES EXISTING
TREATMENT DELAYS IN 2018, THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB 1810, A
BILL WHICH SERVED COURTS WHICH
GRANTED COURTS THE DISCRETION TO
DIVERT SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL
PERSONS FROM JAILS AND INTO
TREATMENT. PRIOR TO AB 1810,
COURTS HAD FEW OPTIONS FOR THOSE
SUFFERING FROM SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS. ABSENT A CONVICTION, AB
1810 CREATED A SEA OF CHANGE IN
CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM, OFFERING PRE PLEA DEAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
RECEIVE TREATMENT IN LIEU OF
INCARCERATION. UNFORTUNATELY, AB
2692 INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD OF
UNDUE CONFINEMENT FOR THOSE
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL ILLNESS BY
REVERSING COURSE AND LIMITING
THE COURTS DISCRETION TO ORDER
THAT THE TERM OF DIVERSION BEGAN
ON THE DATE THE COURT FINDS THE
PERSON ELIGIBLE AS OPPOSED TO
THE DATE THAT THE PERSON ENTERS
TREATMENT. WE'RE HOPEFUL FOR
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS, BUT WE
REMAIN IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. OTHER
OPPOSITION LESLIE CALDWELL,
HOUSTON, FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE, OUR
ASSOCIATION. I WAS REFLECTING
BACK YESTERDAY WHEN I WAS
PREPARING MY NOTES, THINKING
ABOUT BEING ON THE FRONT PAGE OF
MY LOCAL NEWSPAPER, THE CONTRA
COSTA TIMES. AT THAT TIME, 35
YEARS AGO, WORRYING ABOUT HOW
LONG IT TOOK FOR MY CLIENTS, MY
IST CLIENTS, TO GET INTO THE
HOSPITAL. THIS IS JUST GOING ON
AND ON AND ON. IT ONLY WAS
RECENTLY THAT THERE WERE LIMITS
PLACED ON HOW LONG A PERSON
COULD BE SITTING IN JAIL,
WAITING TO GET TO THE HOSPITAL.
THE AMENDMENT DOES NOT CHANGE
OUR POSITION BECAUSE AB 2692
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD OF
UNDUE CONFINEMENT FOR THOSE
SUFFERING SAU STILL INCREASES
THAT TIME FOR THOSE SUFFERING
FROM MENTAL ILLNESS BY ALLOWING
ADDITIONAL TIME, AND EXTENDING
TIME LIMITS. THIS INCREASE IN
TIME WOULD PERPETUATE EXISTING
TREATMENT DELAYS, WHICH ARE
ALREADY A PROBLEM IN ALL
COUNTIES FOR EXAMPLE, IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY, INDIVIDUALS
MAY BE IN CUSTODY FOR MORE THAN
SIX MONTHS AFTER AN ORDER
GRANTING DIVERSION BUT PRIOR TO
ADMISSION TO TREATMENT, EVEN IN
WELL RESOURCED COUNTIES LIKE
ALAMEDA COUNTY, PEOPLE HAVE TO
WAIT 2 OR 3 MONTHS FOR A BED. IT
IS NOT A MATTER OF MORE TIME, IT
IS A MATTER OF RESOURCES. AB
2692 CREATES INEQUITIES WITHIN
AND ACROSS COUNTY LINES THAT
RAISE DUE PROCESS AND EQUAL
PROTECTION CONCERNS. INDIVIDUALS
MAY SERVE DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT
TERMS OF DIVERSION BASED SOLELY
ON ANY GIVEN COUNTY'S AVAILABLE
RESOURCES, DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTING PERSONS OF COLOR AND
THOSE WHO LIVE IN
UNDER-RESOURCED COMMUNITIES.
FURTHER, IT RUNS THE RISK OF
DISINCENTIVIZING THE THOSE
FACING LESSER SENTENCES TO AGREE
TO LENGTHIER PERIODS OF
DIVERSION. WE KNOW THAT JAIL IS
NO PLACE FOR THE MENTALLY ILL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ME TOOS.
BOTH IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
GARRETT HAMILTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. SHIRVAN
NIZAMI INITIATED JUSTICE ACTION
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU, ERIC HENDERSON, ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS UNITED
FOR A RESPONSIBLE BUDGET AND
VERA, CALIFORNIA, IN OPPOSITION.
YOLANDA NAVARETTE ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE, INITIATE
JUSTICE ACTION, FELONY MURDER
ELIMINATION PROJECT AND FAMILIES
UNITED TO END LOOP IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. KARI. OUR
SYSTEM IMPACTED AND ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
AND ME TOOS, AS WELL AS
EMPOWERING EMPOWERING WOMEN
IMPACTED BY INCARCERATION. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER SPEAKERS,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY SAYING
THIS. THIS BILL GIVES THOSE WITH
THE GREATEST NEED THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE FULLEST
AMOUNT OF TREATMENT. WE HAVE
ASKED FOR DATA THAT WOULD SAY
THIS WOULD ENHANCE
INCARCERATION. WE'VE NEVER
GOTTEN ANY OF IT. AND I WOULD
REMIND THOSE IN OPPOSITION THAT
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION CONSISTS
OF MANY THINGS. SOME OF IT IS
INPATIENT, SOME OF IT IS YOU GO
TO A HALFWAY HOUSE AND SOME OF
IT IS OUTPATIENT TREATMENT. SO
THOSE 24 MONTHS CAN CONSIST OF
ANY NUMBER OF WAYS THAT WE ARE
GETTING PEOPLE HELP. SO WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND
I VOTE. THANK YOU. AND DO WE
HAVE A MOTION? SENATOR WIENER
MOVES THE BILL. CAN WE GET A
ROLL CALL, PLEASE? ITEM 19 AB
2692 PAP IN MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WAHAB, I, I SEYARTO BRADFORD
SKINNER. WIENER WIENER. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL'S ON CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL PRESENT THE FINAL
BILL, FILE ITEM 16 AB 2432. AND
THANK YOU TO YOUR STAFF. WHO'S
BEEN PATIENTLY WAITING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND APOLOGIES FOR MY
TARDINESS WAS OVER IN THE
CAPITOL HAVING A HEARING. AND
THANK YOU TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL ASSISTANCE
ON THIS MEASURE. I'M PLEASED
TODAY TO PRESENT AB 2432, WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH A PERMANENT
SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS
SERVING VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIME
MODELED ON THE BIPARTISAN
FEDERAL VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT OR
VOCA. AB 2432 MAKES IT EASIER
FOR STATE AND LOCAL PROSECUTORS
TO HOLD CORPORATE BAD ACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE, SUPPORT CRIME
VICTIMS, AND PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES IN SEVERAL IMPORTANT
WAYS. FIRST, THE ENHANCED
PENALTIES IN THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT CORPORATE BAD ACTORS
CANNOT EVADE RESPONSIBILITY WHEN
THEY DEFRAUD OR EXPLOIT
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS, OR
ILLEGALLY POLLUTE OUR
ENVIRONMENT, THEY WILL LITERALLY
PAY FOR THEIR CRIMES. SECOND,
ENSURING THAT BAD ACTORS ARE
HELD FULLY ACCOUNTABLE WILL
ENHANCE DETERRENCE AND HELP
PROTECT RESIDENTS ACROSS OUR
STATE AND FINALLY, AND PERHAPS
MOST IMPORTANTLY, AB 2432 WILL
HELP TO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE VITAL AND IN MANY CASES,
EVEN LIFE SAVING SERVICES TO
CRIME VICTIMS IN CALIFORNIA,
INCLUDING VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND CHILD ABUSE. THIS YEAR,
CRIME VICTIM SERVICE PROVIDERS
FACE A REDUCTION OF $170 MILLION
IN FEDERAL FUNDING, A CUT OF
APPROXIMATELY 40. THIS WOULD BE
DEVASTATING IN PRACTICE, THIS
WOULD MEAN FEWER STAFF, LONGER
WAIT TIMES, LESS ASSISTANCE, AND
FEWER TO THE VITAL SERVICES
PROVIDED BY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SERVICE PROVIDERS. RAPE CRISIS
CENTERS, LEGAL ASSISTANCE, AND
NONPROFITS THAT WORK WITH
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING TO
PREVENT THIS TRAGEDY. AB 2423
WOULD CREATE A STATE ANALOG TO
VOCA SO THAT WE CAN BETTER
SUPPORT THESE ESSENTIAL PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES. I'M PROUD THAT
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION OF PROSECUTORS,
VICTIM SERVICES ORGANIZATIONS
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE GROUPS THAT
INCLUDES ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB
BONTA, THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE, THE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING,
THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S LAW
CENTER, SMART JUSTICE, AND THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION, AMONG MANY OTHERS.
IT HAS NO RECORDED OPPOSITION.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE ARE
BONNIE RICE, THE SRT SRT PROGRAM
COORDINATOR AT REACH, WHICH
PROVIDES CRITICAL SERVICES TO
CRIME VICTIMS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY, AND EVAN ACRION, SPECIAL
ASSISTANT TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ON WHITE COLLAR AND
CORPORATE PROSECUTIONS. THANK
YOU AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. YOU WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
WAHAB AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS BONNIE RICE AND I AM THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT RESPONSE TEAM
PROGRAM COORDINATOR AT REACH OF
RAPE CRISIS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CENTER THAT SERVES
HEMET AND SAN JACINTO VALLEY AND
THE SURROUNDING RURAL
COMMUNITIES. I HAVE WORKED WITH
REACH SINCE 2015. IN THAT TIME,
I HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
ADVOCATING FOR HUNDREDS OF
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE
DURING E.R VISITS FOR FORENSIC
MEDICAL EXAMS, LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTERVIEWS, AND COURT
APPOINTMENTS. I HAVE SEEN
SURVIVORS ON THEIR WORST
POSSIBLE DAYS, AS WELL AS IN
THEIR MOST TRIUMPHANT MOMENTS OF
RECOVERY AND MY CURRENT ROLE. I
WORK WITH A MULTIDISCIPLINARY
TEAM TO BUILD A WEB OF SUPPORT
FOR VICTIMS OF SEXUALLY VIOLENT
CRIMES. REACH AND MANY OF OUR
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS ARE FUNDED
THROUGH THE FEDERAL VICTIMS OF
CRIME ACT, COMMONLY KNOWN AS
VOCA. BOCA. FUNDING HAS
FLUCTUATED SIGNIFICANTLY OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS, AND THE FUND
HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO PAY OUT
PROGRAMS AS STABLE AT STABLE
RATES. THIS FLUCTUATION CREATES
HOLES IN OUR WEB OF SUPPORT IN
ADDITION TO BEING A SERVICE
PROVIDER, I AM ALSO THE ADOPTIVE
MOTHER OF A DAUGHTER THAT WAS
SEX TRAFFICKED AS A TODDLER BY
HER BIOLOGICAL PARENTS. THE
SERVICES THIS BILL WILL FUND
SAVED MY FAMILY. THEY PROVIDED
COUNSELING AND SUPPORT AS FOR MY
DAUGHTER EDUCATION FOR ME AND
ALLOWED MY DAUGHTER THE
OPPORTUNITY AS AN ADULT TO
DECIDE FOR HERSELF WHO SHE WILL
BE WITHOUT LONG TERM STATE
SOLUTION. THERE IS A REAL
POSSIBILITY VICTIM SERVICES WILL
DISAPPEAR AND VICTIMS LIKE MY
DAUGHTER WILL BE LEFT
FLOUNDERING ON THEIR OWN. WE
WILL NO LONGER BE THERE TO
SUPPORT VICTIMS ON THEIR WORST
DAYS, NOR WILL THERE BE A PATH
TO RECOVERY. CALIFORNIA RELIES
HEAVILY ON FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
VICTIM SERVICES, AND THE CUTS TO
THE FEDERAL FUNDING IMPACT EVERY
LEVEL OF SERVICE. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO DO BETTER. CALIFORNIA
CRIME VICTIMS DESERVE BETTER.
THEY NEED PERMANENT, SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING. WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S WORK IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET TO ADDRESS THIS
YEAR'S CRISIS, BUT WE ALSO NEED
A LONG TERM FIX. AB 2432 BY
ASSEMBLYMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL CREATES A NEW, NECESSARY
ONGOING FUNDING, SUPPORT AND
STREAM TO SUPPORT CRIME VICTIMS.
THIS FUNDING SAVES REAL LIVES.
REAL PEOPLE, REAL FAMILIES AND
REAL COMMUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
. NEXT SPEAKER, THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR, AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS AB 2432
WITH YOU ON BEHALF OF ONE OF THE
CO-SPONSORS, ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROB BONTA. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK AND APPLAUD ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GABRIEL CERVANTES AND
REYES FOR THEIR JOINT AUTHORSHIP
OF THE BILL. CURRENTLY, THE
DEFAULT PENALTY WHEN ONE IS
CONVICTED OF A CRIME, WHETHER
THE DEFENDANT IS A CORPORATION
OR AN INDIVIDUAL IS $10,000 PER
COUNT FOR EACH FELONY. THIS IS A
REASONABLY FAIRLY ANTIQUATED
AMOUNT, AND WE'D LIKE CALIFORNIA
TO JOIN THE UNITED STATES. AND A
NUMBER OF OUR SISTER STATES IN
RAISING THOSE AMOUNTS OF
CORPORATE PENALTIES. THIS BILL
WOULD CENTER AROUND A FINE FOR
CORPORATIONS ONLY. THIS WOULDN'T
APPLY TO INDIVIDUALS AND A
CORPORATION CONVICTED OF A CRIME
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO A FINE IN
THE COURT'S DISCRETION OF UP TO
TWO TIMES THE AMOUNT THAT WAS
STOLEN, OR THE AMOUNT OF DAMAGE
OR HARM THAT WAS CAUSED. THAT'S
THE GENERAL TENOR OF THE OF THE
BILL. IT WOULD APPLY TO
CORPORATE DEFENDANTS ONLY, AND
IT WOULD SUPPLEMENT THE EXISTING
FINANCIAL PENALTY ENHANCEMENTS,
THE BILL WOULD HOLD CORPORATIONS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR CRIMINAL
WRONGDOING, AND IT STILL
REQUIRES A PROSECUTOR TO PROVE
INTENT WITH EACH CRIME THAT'S
BEING CHARGED TO CONVICT THE
DEFENDANT BEFORE THEY OPPOSE THE
PROPOSED ENHANCEMENT COULD BE
SOUGHT. AS MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUES, THIS MAKES AB 2432 A
WIN WIN. IT RAISES MONEY FOR
VICTIMS FOR VICTIM SERVICES AND
IT ALSO SHOULD ACT AS A
DETERRENT TO CORPORATIONS ONCE
THESE NEW PENALTIES START BEING
IMPOSED, I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL MOVE ON TO ME
. TWO'S MADAM CHAIR MEMBER DAN
FELIZARDO, ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT AND
ALSO IN SUPPORT FROM THE CRIME
VICTIMS ALLIANCE. THANK YOU,
SHERIFF NIZAMI INITIATED JUSTICE
ACTION AND ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND AS A CONSTITUENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MICAELA SCHUNK,
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SARAH
BRENNAN ON BEHALF OF VALOR,
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL. WE
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
FOR THEIR DEDICATION TO THIS
IMPORTANT FUNDING BACKFILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AGAIN. JUST
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE KIM LEWIS,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GARRETT HAMILTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. SUPPORT
KERRY ARZATE FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION AND OUR YOUTH
IMPACTED BY INCARCERATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. YOLANDA
NAVARETTE, ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE FELONY MURDER
ELIMINATION PROJECT, FAMILIES
UNITED TO END LOOP AND INITIATE
JUSTICE ACTION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ELLEN LAY,
ON BEHALF OF ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MIA BRITTINGHAM WITH
GREENBERG TRAURIG, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT.
GLEN BACKUS ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT AND
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE ACTION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BRITTNEY
SPENCER, REPRESENTING HAVEN OF
STANISLAUS COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ERIC
HENDERSON ON BEHALF OF SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT. MOVING THE COMMENTARY
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS, SEEING
NONE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
YEAH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS,
I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT SOLUTION TO A
CHALLENGE THAT'S FACING US ALL.
PROUD THAT WE WERE ABLE TO BRING
SO MANY STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE
OFTEN ON OPPOSITE SIDES OF
ISSUES TOGETHER AROUND THE
SOLUTION, AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
CURTIS. OH, ME? YES. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SALADO. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL?
VOTE PLEASE. ITEM 16 AB 2432.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB. AYE, AYE.
SATO. SATO. AYE. BRADFORD
SCANNER. WIENER. SO THAT BILL IS
ON CALL. THANK YOU. NØ. I NEED
TO HOP ON. I NEED TO ADD ON.
JUST HAPPENED. HE HAS A COUPLE.
FINISH ME OUT. CLOSE ME OUT. CAN
WE LIFT THE CALL, PLEASE? SURE
THAT I TOLD THE OTHER SENATORS
ARE HERE. I'M ONLY WORRIED ABOUT
19. I'M ONLY WORRIED ABOUT ME.
ITEM 19 AB 2692. HAPPEN MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. SATO I, SATO I BRADFORD
WILL COME. WHEN SARAH TOOK US
BACK.
JEFFERSON AND BRADFORD. LET'S
LIFT THE CALL, PLEASE, ITEM ONE
AB 459, CALL. A MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0. SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE. IT'S STILL ON CALL.
THAT'S STILL ON CALL. ITEM 16,
AB 2432. GABRIEL. MOTION WAS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE IS 2 TO 0. SKINNER SKINNER.
AYE. WIENER. WIENER. AYE. ALL
RIGHT, THAT'S ON CALL. IS WIENER
DONE WITH EVERYTHING? YES.
YOU'RE GOOD. GOOD. IT MUST BE
NICE. THANK SORRY ABOUT ITEM 19.
AB 20, AB 2692. PAPIN. MOTION
WAS Dð PASSED, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE
YOU JUST NEED WRAP AROUND THAT.
I THINK THAT'S IT FOR HER. NO, I
GOT ONE MORE ITEM. 25 AB 3088
FRIEDMAN. MOTION WAS Dð PASSED,
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 1. SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE. ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT. THOSE BILLS ARE STILL ON
CALL. BRADFORD SHOULD BE ON HERE
IN A MINUTE. OTHERWISE. GOOD.
YES. YOU'RE GOOD. OKAY. GOOD
JOB. ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT, LET'S
LIFT THE CALL. USUALLY WE HAVE
TO RIGHT. ITEM ONE. ITEM ONE AB
459. CALL MOTION WAS DUE. PASSED
TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. CURRENT
VOTE IS 3 TO 1. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE. THAT BILL'S OUT.
ITEM 16 AB 2432. GABRIEL. MOTION
WAS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0. BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT. ITEM 19.
SORRY. ITEM 18 FIRST AB 2629.
HAYNIE MOTION WAS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 4
TO 0 BRADFORD. BRADFORD I THAT
BILLS OUT. ITEM 19 AB 2692.
PAPPAN MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 4 TO 0 BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I THAT BILLS OUT. ALL
RIGHT. HOLD ON. REASON I THINK
IS THE LAST ONE AB 20 I MEAN
ITEM 25 AB 3088 FRIEDMAN MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 3
TO 1 BRADFORD BRADFORD I THAT
BILLS OUT AND WE ARE DONE. WE
ARE ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.